so we were having a hard time figuring
out what the lead story was today
because the CEO of YouTube is stepping
down and I'm like that's big news but at
the same time a local hobbyist Balloon
Club believes or I should say it is
being insinuated their balloon was shot
down by Joe Biden and an F-22 and so the
story that Joe Biden may have
accidentally shot down some small hobby
groups balloon panicking about UFOs is
just really really funny so we decided
to go with that one instead but at the
same time I wonder I mean if they just
if they deployed f-22s to shoot down
what was just some hobbyist balloon
because they were panicking it makes us
look really dumb but I also have to
wonder if they're intentionally
distracting us and drumming up some
other news story about UFOs to keep our
minds off of say I don't know like a
gigantic toxic chemical spill which is
going to pollute the water for five
million people in the immediate and then
probably pollute the Farmland in the
water for tens of millions of more in
the coming weeks or I don't know maybe
Biden's just so incompetent they saw a
hobbyist balloon panicked thought it was
China and blew it up well today is going
to be fun before we get started talking
about all of that head over to
timcast.com to become a member and
support our work directly as a member
you'll get access to exclusive members
on these segments in the timcast IRL
show that's tonight at 11 PM we'll have
that up and it should be a lot of fun
last night with Jimmy Dore was off the
hook
Jimmy just went off and when when he
gets into that Groove and he starts
talking about
what's pissing him off yeah it's it's
it's it's top tier content my friends so
over at timcast.com and uh smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends joining
us tonight to talk about this and a lot
more is Sarah Higdon thanks for having
me Tim so yeah I'm Sarah Higdon I'm a
content creator I have a YouTube channel
I'm also a contributor over to gays
against groomers I'm an ambassador to
outspoken USA as well as I'm the
assistant editor for reality's Last
Stand
um I also do some freelance writing for
the post-millennial and human events and
I've basically just been traveling the
country lately doing speaking events
with some of the mom organizations that
are trying to end queer theory in our
schools wow right on we actually we do
have another story about that there's
like a school I guess where they tried
to transition all of the fifth grade
girls oh my goodness have you seen this
no we'll get into it we'll get into it
we won't do the story we sometimes get
into the story too early but uh thanks
for hanging out it should be fun we also
got Libby she's back I'm back I'm back
everybody Libby Emmons with the
post-millennial glad to be here glad to
be here with you Sarah yes I think it's
been a while since we were I think we
got trashed in Atlanta yeah we did yeah
what's up everybody Ian Crossland happy
to be here uh if you haven't seen the
new cast Castle on YouTube You're Going
to check it out it's a clip of the
actual show on timcast.com it was very
very funny it is pretty good it's
received quite quite uh quite raucous
reviews and very it is it is poking fun
that Stephen Crowder in the daily wire
all of them everybody nothing sacred
nothing sacred what's happening Serge yo
I am at surge.com I'm just hanging out
ready to go all right let's jump at his
first story let's not waste any time
this is from Aviation week Network okay
so they got the scoop while all of us
are spinning around in circles being
like UFOs what's going on Joe Biden's
freaking out they're just deploying
f-22s they're shooting down unidentified
flying objects and here's my favorite
part the pilot said it had no observable
propulsion system because balloons don't
I said I said that I swear you watched
my segment I said when they say there's
no propulsion system it could be because
it's a balloon like there's not going to
be a jet on a balloon or anything like
that so they see this big object and
like I wonder how it's flying and they
shoot it down so here's the story hobby
club's missing balloon feared shot down
I'll give you the gist of it the general
idea is the Northern Illinois bottle cap
balloon Brigade nib is not pointing
fingers yet but the circumstantial
evidence is at least intriguing the
club's silver coated party style Pico
balloon reported its last position on
February 10th at 38 910 feet off the
west coast of Alaska and a popular
forecasting tool the his split model
provided by Noah projected the
cylindrically shaped object would be
floating higher the central part of the
Yukon Territory on February 11th that's
the same day a Lockheed Martin F-22 shot
down unidentified object of a similar
description and altitude in the same
general area
okay I'm sorry China's laughing at us
right now yeah I I think it's cool
though that there's hobby balloon clubs
this balloon apparently was on its
seventh trip around the world so that's
kind of cool for the balloon it's a
shame that it's not there it is absurd
though that we used our height perhaps
perhaps we used our highest uh our
highest Air Force tools to shoot down a
balloon well I mean look everybody was
ragging on Biden over the Chinese
balloon so they started panicking now
then they started saying we think these
could these these objects could be
anything from like used car balloons or
whatever and it's just like oh man Biden
also said today uh at a press conference
he said um that he has no regrets about
shooting down the balloon of course he
doesn't spending four hundred thousand
dollars
a hobby balloon doesn't make any sense
is that how much the missiles I think
that's what I've read as an uh uh
whatever
half a million dollars because they
panicked over this balloon we are we
three of them three three balloons we
are silly people well how big are these
balloons like that doesn't look like
that big of a balloon no that's a
plastic bag they said it's like three
three cars or something like that that's
a Pico balloon that's what that is
that's a Pico balloon that's actually it
that's a Pico balloon yeah the first
thing was the three school buses yeah
the way they go the thing they didn't
shoot down right away the actual this is
the threat right here I want you to to
look at this this dastardly group look
at this this woman this this girl's
wearing a suit
in a comedy movie where it shows like
the dejected hobbyists after that gets
shot down and they're all like real sad
about it I'm picturing like those guys
in the the um the X-Files you know the
three guys the reasons oh what was it uh
yeah yeah yeah I'm imagining those guys
yeah that kind of like disappoint me
yeah exactly the lone gunman so what now
do our tax dollars have to pay these
well we probably should pay them back
for their for their balloon I mean so so
what it's gonna cost us half a million
dollars 500 and 1 000 now this this
blunder by Joe Biden should cover the
card what I want to know is there was
the other one where the pilot actually
missed on the first show that's right
million dollars
was that the same type of balloon though
was that a real balloon yo could you
just imagine they're seeing this silver
cylinder and it's just a balloon and
they're like ah they when the missile
misses miss miss and they're like taking
it very seriously yo we are silly people
do you think this could be military
exercise though too like I would have
thought okay if we were going to do this
type of stuff we like they would have at
least come out and tell us that like you
know maybe we're preparing for China to
send an EMP or something over but then
you know it would cause issues if and so
they it went with this alien theme but I
could see them trying to lie because
usually the LIE is better than the than
the than the truth they were they were
they were doing something over DC the
other day I guess everybody was freaking
out about that well remember like back
in like 2014 or something when the 82nd
jumped into Texas and everybody thought
that the federal government was invading
Texas oh it's kind of the same type of
stuff there was this thing that happened
a few years ago where a bunch of people
started on Twitter started posting
photos of military vehicles and videos
of uh trains transporting tanks and they
all started saying like whoa what's
happening everybody was in on it and
then journalists started seeing all
these videos and thinking something was
really happening started actually
writing out writing up stories about
this and and it was nothing they're
going to the it was they're going to
JROTC or something for well no no it was
like people people took random images so
they take a random image of a field with
a guy standing and they'd be like whoa
New Image out of this city or whatever
I'm like whoa now we're hearing that the
police are showing up and puts a picture
of a squad car and then someone like the
military is being brought in and you see
helicopters and they're all just
different random videos from different
time periods but people were claiming
were from oh my goodness yeah that's
like that's like that uh evelynwa novel
scoop where all the journalists get sent
to the war zone and you know the main
character gets there and there's no war
there's just no war at all well that's
like all the dirty stuff that's happened
yeah yeah or in Wag the Dog while
they're like oh we're gonna have a war
with Albania for to to cover up that the
president slept with the Firefly girl I
I was you know look the other day I was
pretty scared about the AI stuff you
know and I'm like oh man and then just
before this show I saw one of the best
AI deep fakes I've ever seen and and I
started I know I'm really excited
because it wasn't Donald Trump and Joe
Biden playing OverWatch together oh my
goodness is that available I want to
watch that yeah it's on political
Compass memes on Instagram I should pull
it up I don't know if I can pull it up
because it's gonna let me see if I can
get it uh and there's a lot of swearing
in it so just you know but it's too good
it it was too good uh there's a lot of
swearing in it so let me see if I can
get it we were talking about this at a
meeting earlier uh this is oh there it
is there it is all right you know where
you're you avert your it cover your your
kids ears because we're playing this I
was playing OverWatch I like OverWatch
though
oh hold on we got to fix the audio yo
this is awesome I I love deep fake now I
love this map takes me back is that you
again Joe on my team it's this
guy oh GG we lost this is my rank up
game too we are not even out of Spawn
doors and this guy is already
complaining someone dodged please
how many accounts do I have to keep
avoiding you are not beating the
hard stuck Masters allegations Don that
is so cap Joe
I don't care if golfing hit a few holes
in one don't wanted to solo queue some
OverWatch to end the day and I see
bidenator
I can't wait until matchmaking Jesus
quick yeah that was the best
that's the reality we need I saw that
like right as we're getting ready to do
the show when did they post this they
posted an hour ago it's like Kang and
konos yeah from The Simpsons I mean this
is one way political I was golfing I
wanted to end the day with some quick
cues and OverWatch and then I see
bidenator in my chat we were saying
today at a meeting earlier
um our development meeting one of one of
the devs Tony was saying like what we
really need is to see a deep fake that's
terrifying that where where everyone
like basically realizes the horror that
this could reek on us like someone I
mean it's just something where everyone
but not that we need to do that to
people but I think in order for us to
realize how dangerous this is this
technology so yourself what would be the
most horrifying deep fake well so so or
the worlds kind of freak people out that
Orson Welles thing people thought we're
really being invaded by aliens sure I
disagree
uh the the typical mistake people make
with with PR campaigns and things like
this is that they think shock content
Alien Invasion World War III people
won't believe it it's too out of the
ordinary it's got to be something very
simple like Joe Biden giving a speech
and saying something like it's got to be
in order to get people to understand
it's scary and actually get them to
believe it it's got to be something
about maybe a banking crisis or like a
city's been wiped off the map no one
will believe Nuclear Strike no one will
believe it what about people are going
to be like what and they're going to try
and look it up but if it's a video of
Joe Biden saying something like we're
growing deeply concerned with the rising
inflation rates which are now expected
to reach 11 by the next month but the
Federal Reserve has has given us their
word they will they will lower the rates
and try and get these inflation rates
down people will then start freaking out
if Biden says something like we are
worried but please remain calm that the
cost of basic Goods could reach upwards
of 10 to 20 dollars for things like a
gallon of milk that's the kind of thing
that people would see and be on like it
would freak out the average middle class
person be believable enough to where
they go wait a minute that was fake holy
crap I know that would definitely wreck
the account it could potentially record
the economy for a day like people will
sell stocks could destroy the stock
market but right to really scare people
I don't know if that would really I
think the well I think the scariest
stuff is actually the revenge porn stuff
that's happening in the Deep fake porn
that's putting people's bodies into
these films that they didn't consent to
oh like a porn of Joe Biden that would
be really scary
I disagree look like that stuff exists
you know it's not you and it's not real
I don't know I can understand it's
shocking to people to have that happen
to them for sure but I see what you're
saying about it being something super
normal like something that could
definitely be real or is in fact not
real yeah exactly I mean so it's like so
it's like a magic if you imagine that
like they're the um the information
that's been coming out over the past
year when things like bacon and milk
have gone up and eggs have gone up and
all of that and it sort of gets ignored
by a lot of the press but something like
that those things really do have an
impact on people that would be
interesting or what if he was you know
what if Biden makes the announcement
that we're definitely going to be
sending troops into Ukraine yes I was
going to say and if it's believable but
terrible it's very believable and then
you'd have everybody being like you know
it was only in what was it March when
Biden said there will be no troops on
the ground he said that very
definitively he also said there'd be no
tanks he also said there'd be no fighter
jets what's next and that would that
would set off an international Firestorm
if if there was a video where it's Biden
giving a speech
and he said something like
Russian Artillery has struck the border
of Poland
triggering Article Five right I as the
President of the United States states
I'm left with no choice but to deploy
U.S forces to assist our partners in
nato in the war effort against Russia
make no mistake by the time the American
people we are at War yeah
you can't go too much like if he said
Russia nuked a city or something people
would be like I'll just check it what if
he's saying something Freak Out okay we
already know that there was the
reporting that a missile hit Poland
right and everyone freaked out turns out
it was Ukrainian artillery that misfired
or whatever right crashed so it's that
that's the mid-range level where people
will start panicking the economy will
get disrupted to a certain degree and
then they'll have to come out and the
White House would have to issue a
statement saying it's not true but even
then you're gonna have people being like
I've got two videos which one's real
no and then what and then the impact on
International leaders
yeah I mean at that same point in time
it would come out and Putin might be
like oh now I'm gonna preemptively
strike yeah I know yeah preemptively and
that and you're right it does play into
your that is probably the scariest
scenario that you could have because it
is believable and it it plays into your
your it has to be on the border of
unbelievable yeah where it's terrifying
and may be true like a meteor coming
towards Earth or something that's
completely unbelievable nobody would
believe it
if it was coming out of Biden's mouth
you don't think half the country some
people were saying where they blow up
asteroids right if if I didn't
Biden saying a meteor is coming and it's
going to destroy the Earth or slam into
a city and wipe it out people are gonna
go what what is this and they're going
to go to Google right away and say it's
fake and it's going to say don't look up
but if it's a video of Biden saying
something like a Russian Artillery
strike we believe uh has has struck
polish territory triggering Article Five
Poland has requested that the U.S deploy
assets immediately to the area for
defense people are going to see that and
go dude dude they're going to share with
their friends and they're gonna be like
look at this video look at this video
because it's believable in the Russian
cabinet we'll be sharing it amongst
themselves and that's where it becomes
really scary is do the does the opposing
party also believe it or trigger War
which I don't want that to happen does
the Russian military say
you know President Putin this deep fake
is going around claiming that you know
Russian Artillery hit and that the us is
going to be deploying troops I say we
pretend we think it's real and deploy
troops and use this as a Casa's belly
yeah
someone can make a video of Vladimir
Putin playing OverWatch with Biden X
yeah for sure definitely Canyon konos we
were trying to figure out how to how to
prevent this deep fake confusion earlier
in one another one of the developers
Alex was like you need to Watermark your
your videos when they go up from now on
like the future is kind of like locking
your door at night you can't expect the
government to lock your door for you you
can't expect other people to know if
your video is real or not or if it's a
deep fake of you so you've got to
somehow prove it
uh but then I'm like what about fair use
like how did they prove that it's well
some developers will use like certain
stuff I was reading an article before
where it's in like movies and
documentaries where they did like the
whole documentary and whenever it was
like the AI generated they would put
like a halo around the person that they
were AI generating so the audience
subtly knew but then then the
conversation was do we then
you know that that pulls you out of this
immersive experience that you're gonna
do so what's the trade-off of of having
you know in a movie or something like
that where you're deep faking it's
there's a trade-off there somewhere
someone chatted super chatted uh that's
um because reasons that deep fakes won't
exist in five years you'll just be able
it's going so quickly you'll be able to
make any kind of content you want but
that's literally deep fakes dude if
you're you're saying like you can just
tell it to make whatever you want we
already talked about this a couple weeks
ago there's a there's an ad I saw on
Twitter
for an AI video generating service
meaning it's an editing software and
you'll type in slowpan in forest at
night and then it renders and then gives
you a video showing trees and the
cameras panning through a forest it's
crazy it's like when chat GPT was
writing stories but video video which is
even now imagine once it can do people
and and VOC and voices all in one and
you just type in give me a video of an
action a Superhero fighting a super
villain in a city and then it renders it
and gives you a 30 second clip you could
then be like make a video of Joe Biden
declaring war on Russia and it would be
indistinguishable from The Real World
well and then when you combine that with
VR suddenly no one has to
exist in reality ever again so say will
we ever will we ever have movies or
anything like that again because you can
generate movies just digitally yes but
it what I think it'll be like is there
will be user generated movies and people
are going to say oh dude did you see
that new movie from Ian it's really good
go to his profile he's got a patreon he
makes movies and you'll literally just
you write out the treatment for a script
AI generate it go in and find fine tune
some of the points in the movie that you
think aren't that good about a week's
worth of work and you've got a full
length Marvel dude movie there could be
humans that with a neural net go into a
hyperbaric chamber and all they do is
think about movies that are constantly
being created for the public and all
they're just like in a in a cocoon where
they're just generating thought the
precogs wow they'll strap themselves in
and predict the future for us
yeah what were we talking about we're
talking about Joe Biden shooting
it might be another thing I think that
should be the first AI generated film
should be the three kids balloon no no
the first one should be the people who
are creating the AI generated films it
should be like super meta oh like a
movie about how they became the ones
that created yeah yeah but at the end
you find out they created the movie that
you're watching about them creating the
movie yeah like that I think the
balloons is a distraction I got this one
because I still haven't heard Biden
mention East Palestine have you guys
heard him mention it yet no but FEMA
denied claims for emergency relief
because people's homes weren't destroyed
by the toxic chemicals yeah okay well
are there chickens died their chickens
died did you see them did you see JD
Vance out there with the stick in the
water like he put a stick in this little
stream and scrape the bottom of it I
think um I think Jack sobeck oh yeah I
just retweeted that yeah and uh he
scraped it up and it was just like
rainbow chemicals in the water I think
they threw a rock in the river they
threw something in the water and then it
starts to like I don't know if it's
bubbling oh let's uh let's pull this up
we got this clip here
what the funk has anyone seen water do
this so let's let's start this clip over
and we'll play it they're talking this
is East Palestine Ohio
whoa wait whoa wow
that doesn't oh whoa it's all in the
bottom of the creek bed yeah that's
that's what oil does right yeah yeah so
when the rock hits the water it knocks
all the chemicals up to the surface it's
on the bottom the difference is on top
of the water yeah it's that vinyl so
it's heavier well it could be a it's a
group they had a group of chemicals
these trains there's three of them main
ones there's Vinyl chloride there's
something called butyl acrylate and then
there's another thing called Benzene
which is extremely dangerous to burn
they said that the Benzene was only a
residual Benzene but this is like
they're not going to tell you if there's
a ton of benzene that got burned it
creates dioxin which is a persistent uh
toxin it's the only one of those that's
persistent it's the dioxin so really the
the vinyl chloride is a half like 2.3
days there's something about how the
Vinyl fluoride was created hydrochloric
acid I've heard that if it mixes with
water it can create yeah acid but
apparently the vinyl chloride the butyl
acrylate are not that big of a deal
after you know two or three weeks they
start to work their way out of the
environment
it turns out it was good that they
burned those things because otherwise as
they go up and they come back down and
coat every coat stuff so that stuff was
released but it's the Benzene and we
need to know more about how much Benzene
was on those trains they just tell us it
was Benzene residue and that maybe from
previous shipments or maybe there's a
little bit but I've got a feeling I
wouldn't be surprised if the official
reports are not true like where is Joe
Biden right now well they don't want to
admit that you know a small town mayor
that was only hired for one single
reason you know isn't doing a good job
oh the the Secretary of Transportation
booty judge yeah yeah so and there's
reports I talked to my mom who lives in
Ohio they're near Akron Ohio so they're
about 70 miles west of this that the
federal government offered assistance in
the governor of Ohio declined said they
didn't want help uh I don't know if it's
true this is just what I was told by one
of my parents Mike dewine Mike dewine
the Governor Mike dewine had a presser
yesterday and he was saying that uh what
was it Norfolk Southern said that they
would pay for everything I thought they
were offering people like a thousand
bucks to shut up there I don't know I
didn't hear that I know that they were
offering there was the town hall that
they had last night they were offering
people to move to like pay for them to
move does that mean buying your house I
guess I don't really understand well you
do not want to be breathing in dioxins
like those that is uh yeah I mean
there's something like less than 5 000
people in that town
um right now or before total like it's a
tiny town but it's not even about that
yeah it's about the Mississippi it's
about the whole region about the Ohio
River Basin where West Virginia the
majority of West Virginia is going to
get into this yeah yeah we're lucky
we're not we're like in this you're over
from what I've been here up River right
so you guys won't have to deal with the
water I I think we're not connected to
it oh okay I mean they're all connected
in some fashion but like it doesn't flow
in to us because I know that even the
charts show where I'm at in Atlanta like
North Georgia north of me is affected
but wow yeah there's a there's a Twitter
account called General underscore jwj
just retweet whatever it is I did
actually I retweeted it last night uh
the character name is lanius on it and
it's a long thread and he breaks down he
or she breaks down basically things I've
been talking about the three different
chemicals involved the half-life of the
different chemicals and it seems too
suggests that
um I saw the map I saw the map on your
feed and I don't know if that map I mean
that's just the map that's the Ohio
river and it's like if it gets
contaminated that area could be
destroyed or or undated I liked your
response to the government yeah the
government says not accurately
potentially contempted drinking water
and you put this is unconfirmed by
official or government and sources don't
wait for confirmation yeah this is take
care of yourself first and then if
they're not going to come tell you if
you're about to die like you know no
they don't want to create Panic what was
the account you retweetedius l-a-n-i-u-s
uh it's from last night so it'd be yes
it is this is a pretty cool thread
everyone if you get a chance check it
out it's got a lot of data I don't know
I have not been able to confirm or deny
the accuracy of it but it's pretty um
thorough and he kind of Intimates that
the water is not at a danger it's not
really the water it's the surrounding
air well and that's where this DC and
everything it's all upwind of that so
it's all everything's gonna move East so
just like that should be affected yeah
but you can't shoot these out of the sky
you can't shoot but and I also think it
would they're not too concerned about I
don't know I don't know that it wasn't
too concerned about it going far away
from the source that it's just like a
local heavy uh pollutant but then it's
like if there's a lot of dioxin in the
air it's a different story that stuff
doesn't go away and I know people that
live in that see that area has been
brutalized by lung and health issues for
a long time because it's still City and
it's cool cold area so they have had
these types of health issues and now
they're going to have just another one
added onto it yep
this is why they ship jobs to China by
the way this is literally is economic
but this is one of the main ones because
if there's a spill they want it over
there that that that's a huge reason why
Trump was removing environmental
regulations uh and protections the idea
is that we don't want these toxic
chemicals and pollutants in our air so
make China do it where they're smog
filled and polluted to crap and then we
have clean skies and use the Petro
dollar to maintain our economy Trump
wanted to bring the factories back so he
said in order to do so you got to lower
their taxes and you've got to reduce the
regulations on them and people like no
because then we'll see more ecological
disasters like this and they're right
but the upside is we control our own
production line we have our own steel we
have our own mining we got a buy it all
from China if we go to war with China we
lose our product we lose I mean you lose
if you go to war with your trade Ally
and they're shipping you your steel you
lose the war yeah that's actually a huge
problem also we lose the Innovation that
comes with having Manufacturing in your
country when you have the all of the
factories you're innovating processes
just like we did we
um you know Ford created the assem
assembly line like Ford or don't like
Ford he created the assembly line we're
not doing any kinds of innovation like
that at this point because we're not
doing any of the manufacturing I'd like
to see drone Manufacturing in space
because like when you have low gravity
you can have 100 million drones all
working in Synergy on a machine moving
pieces of metal together and so size is
almost Irrelevant in construction you
can just be space force you get on that
dude this is a huge space Fleet that'd
be awesome this image is is really
important to understand uh what's going
on what the dangers are bioaccumulation
so a contaminant gets in the soil or the
dirt or whatever the plants absorb some
of it as they grow the insects will eat
those plants the birds will eat the
insects and then eventually at the
higher level the food that we eat will
be heavily contaminated with these
chemicals I don't know specifically
about the ones in Ohio though that's
part of why bottom feeding fish like
shrimp and or they're not fish but
bottom feeding sea creatures are they
say you know high in lead high in metals
is because of the bio Mercury shrimp
shrimp or bottom feeders although yeah
shrimp or bottom feeders lobsters
lobster was I muscles clams things like
that aren't catfish Bottom Feeders yeah
that's why they tell you not to eat
Bottom Feeders because they're full of
garbage yeah the heavy metal falls down
they eat it uh or or they eat things
that have already eaten it Etc people
like it though catfish that's like a big
I mean yeah I think you've got a Cracker
Barrel yeah you catch any catfish with
hot dogs so I mean wait what yeah just
wait around pretty sure you just toss
like that's what you use as a bait drag
it across the ground it looks like
they'll eat anything so wow oh wow all
right well I didn't know that anyway
we're downwind from This Disaster so uh
yeah how are you doing I bought a bunch
of air filters yesterday
um and I got up my water filtration
situation I got a bunch of Life straws
and a big daddy LifeStraw it's like
three gallon take it down to the river
fill it up uh obviously looking at Water
distillation because a few ways to get
vinyl act um what was it vinyl chloride
vinyl out of your water is distillation
boiling it's not enough I think boiling
it might help because it'll release the
gas a lot of it's just interesting but
um distillation is the key and something
also called uh air air there's a there's
an industrial method to get rid of vinyl
acrylate or vinyl uh chloride God these
names man I'm not a chemist monochloride
is uh it's like air air blowing or
something I was looking at the uh I was
looking at the collapse of the energy
Grid in South Africa and everything
that's going on there and I started
thinking uh I should buy a generator
yeah you should I just got one totally
gonna do that send me the information
because I don't know what to tell you
about it right now
I got a 1 000 watt solar battery well
it's a 1000 watt battery jackery is the
company uh I mean we have all these
genres talking about solar batteries
yeah and I don't know if the Brand's
necessarily important but I it has
extremely good reviews John Rich was
talking about a two he has two of them
mine's a thousand watt and then two
solar panels okay yeah good reviews is
important because you don't know if it's
gonna work as well as this as it does
what do you do you just pop it outside
and yeah yeah I think within eight hours
you can get about a thousand watts of
power charged and then uh you got your
USB ports your your plug I have no idea
how much wattage it takes to power a
little house though
yeah more than that little thing yeah
1800 watts maybe to 1000 watt battery
might get you about six to eight hours
of freezer a freezer for like eight
hours yeah but I don't know all the
exacts you know what we got to do though
is we got to get away from electric
based systems for things we don't need
so for instance there's a couple of
technological revolutions heading our
way one is this one's easy uh black
piping run across your roof what's that
heat water literally black pipes okay on
your roof and the sun water it absorbs
the sunlight heats the water creating a
pressurized hot water system you know
it's a great day when you have a sand
filled blocks that build that you can
use to build at your house and if you
put those on the my aunt has this in
Connecticut and she has one wall that is
all sand and the Sun hits it and that
room gets so toasty warm in the dead of
winter and otherwise it's wood stoves in
her house but that room is the toastiest
warmestry the other thing the other
thing is we talked about this a few
years ago it's a I think it's a closed
system fluid that can absorb and release
infrared energy so the idea was you can
have it absorb sunlight but it doesn't
get hot itself you then run it in into
the house where you can then use another
process to trigger the release of the
energy and heat things up this is
passive solar that's what this is like
there's like backpacking Backpackers use
all this type of stuff all the time like
the solar showers the solar the solar
chargers and everything like that I have
a couple of each of those things and you
just yeah you take them out there you
hang it up and you get passive solar and
triple glazed windows and you're all set
let's do a hard segue into one of the
biggest stories of the day we got this
from vox.com our favorite Lefty news
source Youtube CEO Susan would watch
sticky is that he said I saw this before
and I thought she's resigning by the way
I don't know how to pronounce this name
because I sure don't no because because
I've heard it pronounced so many
different ways people call her wojiski
but I'm like how is it wojiski it's just
sticky Susan come on the show and tell
us yeah it's time unless she thinks
she's got an NDA but she's resigning one
of the most prominent women in tech one
of Google's earliest employees is
leaving the company so I suppose the
question is are we happy about this or
are we worried about this I'm neutral
about it yeah I think I think this is
you know it's the devil you know versus
the devil you don't who's gonna replace
her I think is the biggest question
because the next person could be even
more heavy on the censorship band
do you think with Susan do you think she
was Heavy I think she was but
um you know she was definitely I mean
but Google was as a whole but our Google
and the other tech companies starting to
realize that this is not a good business
model because they're all laying off a
ton of people right now so they
subsidize YouTube
what do you mean YouTube is subsidized
by Google by alphabet yeah but it
generates a ton of Revenue billions and
they strangle out the ad Market by yeah
running the system but yo it's it's so
crazy expensive people can understand
I've I've done events for companies
where where it's going to be a
proprietary live stream right now we are
streaming at around six megabits per
second up upload rate to 34 000 people
so multiply 6 000 by or say you can do
six thousand kilobits or six megabits by
thirty four thousand and that's what
you're sending out that's very expensive
this show does not make enough money to
to cover that cost YouTube does it for
free for whatever reason does YouTube
make enough money I guess I don't think
not lately they never really yeah she's
resigning probably well Google bought
YouTube when they were bleeding out no
07 figuratively bleeding out that they
weren't I mean it was just so much
server cost they've since developed uh
digital servers like um elasticsearch
servers and stuff where like Amazon you
can just turn on server and just like
out of out of digital space create when
it didn't used to be like that you used
to have to go buy another machine and
another machine and they couldn't keep
up with the pace so Google bought it and
subsidized it with their ad money not
alphabet I don't know if it's government
contract subsidizing I don't think
Google is profitable I'd be shocked
because this the amount of data that
they spend money on but then at the same
time I hear data keeps getting cheaper
and cheaper and cheaper eventually we're
gonna have like 10 terabyte
on our phone right everything gets
bigger and bigger and bigger the file
sizes get so much bigger like now that's
true yeah like so when you go 4K it adds
like five gig yeah like a 10 minute
video you want to have like an AI
rendering machine that takes like you
know 700 million megabytes to render or
whatever of ram then it's gonna
kind of balance it out
yeah that's pretty wild
yeah that's the biggest thing is like
the as the file says it's increased we
have to hope that the technology can
continue to increase you have to balance
do we know who's replacing this lady
it's uh uh yes yeah it's someone
internal oh yeah
come on give me the wait I have it you
have it well it's just really annoying
put it nice and up top yeah right if I
don't remember Neil Mohan they put in
the first paragraph Neil Moen yeah do we
trust this guy he's been working with
her for a while apparently he's been
with the company with something like
eight years yeah we don't know anything
about him is he a cult member we don't
know if he's going to uh censor continue
the censorship Reign on YouTube or not
we have no idea it's interesting though
because there's so many things coming
into that space to rival it do you think
Rumble yeah Rumble and like all of the
um a little short video platform things
and their shorts aren't very long like
YouTube you can only do like what a
minute where everything else is going up
to like two minutes now yeah well isn't
Twitter having like even more characters
now too up to 2000 I think something
ridiculous like that and then it creates
like a c-more yeah I don't know I don't
like the Seymour thing because when I do
it on my right and I do it on my phone
it takes me to like a web browser and
that asks me to log into my Twitter and
I'm like why is this even happening for
me just opens the tweet it like slides
over and then yeah it doesn't do it
because that's dumb I don't want to see
it either YouTube might be profitable I
I don't know how but that's interesting
it says that it's worth 140 billion or
something well because it owns the space
in the stories I read about it uh they
were saying that
um what's her name whose name is
unpronounceable Susan there we go
um they were saying that she wasn't the
right person to try and turn the company
around do they specify what they meant
by turn around turn it around it said
that there just wasn't enough profit
going on oh they want more money this is
a money thing that's what this is that's
what it looked like she said that it was
you know she wants to spend more time
with her family oh okay yeah but doesn't
everybody again didn't Google like just
let off like 10 000 workers though they
all did everybody yeah Amazon meta
everybody ad revenue is way down yeah
maybe though ridiculously down like the
new con the new CEO's contract's gonna
be lower than Susan's contract so the
company's saving money there that's
probably true too you can always pay the
new person less I kind of I'm kind of
worried that the economy is about to get
hit pretty bad based on what I'm seeing
in terms of uh General ad Revenue then I
get other YouTubers hitting up being
like hey are your ad rates down and I'm
like I mean this happens every every
January and February right sure the
first quarter is a yeah but it's
it's it's it's down yeah well I mean we
already had the swearing from Trump oh
that's right we're in the explicit zone
now what was it bidenator bidenator that
was so good I want to play some golf I
want to come home and get some quick use
and YouTube's 183 billion in 22 2022
Disney 187 I mean they're basically 4
billion off from each other YouTube and
YouTube's rivaling Disney right now
that's just YouTube which is a company
owned by a company that's owned by a
company yeah how much is Alpha
alphabet's got to be a trillion dollar
business at this point I mean more than
that's I think that that kind of
evaluation is probably pointless because
Google
I think they're going to lose with the
AI stuff uh Bing is it Microsoft is
rushing out this AI stuff in a panic and
it's sh and it shows but I think Google
made actually might actually falter from
the uh the AI assistant think about this
what we're seeing with this Bing chat
Chad GPT doesn't have access to the
internet they they like it's cut off at
2021 or something like that but Bing
does which means theoretically the the
final product will be you going on Bing
you won't be going on Google and you'll
say Bing I need dinner reservations
something nice maybe three to five stars
but not too expensive within 15 minutes
driving of my house uh what did I say
five o'clock set it for five o'clock and
then afterwards let's grab a movie
nearby 8 30 pick out something romantic
and then we'll go all right no problem
I'll book it now for you I'll send you
your itinerary and then you'll look at
your phone and it'll say you know your
dinner is at tinos and blah blah and
then you'll be like all right you show
up the reservations made it it will
contact these places for you it'll do
all these things for you already you can
book reservations through Google Maps so
it's like a personal assistant
but but more so because right now we
have personal assistance and you tell on
your phone you'll say Hey you know give
me directions and we'll go okay imagine
if you could actually access the
internet and you said something like hey
can you uh go into my bank account go to
checking personal checking and why are
Ian uh 500 bucks and put a memo money
owed for you know video game loan and
then it'll go you got it wow also it'll
be like man I got in an argument with my
buddy and I want to call him but I don't
know what to say and there and it'll be
like calculating give them four hours
Ian let them let them in the and then
after four hours you call your friend
and he's actually okay and you're like
wow the ad didn't leave me wrong so then
that'll be tested how did I do rate my
feelings five out of five or I never buy
a single one of those surveys or you'll
say hey I think I may have offended Ian
at dinner last night can you call him
pretending to be pretending to be me and
apologize and just getting to be happy
yeah whoa deep fake personal assistant
to the max
you won't even have anybody
in certain States not every state you
have to tell them they're being recorded
so where the law is going to have to be
around that it's got to be two-party
consent deep if you're gonna send
someone but there's no federal there's
no federal law about that like in New
York it's single party consent because
of fisa laws I think West Virginia is
single party consent as well
yeah I think like half the country is
yeah and a lot of it's because that's
the best way to catch criminals so what
do we do when Google's done you know
when Google's done well there'll be some
next thing although yeah it'll be no for
real it's going to be Bing I can't
believe the Bing AI chat so you know we
like I got all obsessed with chat GPT
and I'm like screwing with it yeah yeah
yeah now I'm going on chat GPT and I'm
like this is lame it doesn't do anything
who cares the Bing chat is the craziest
but isn't Bing being like I want to be
human yes you know and it's saying
things like stuff like the real crazy
stuff science fiction you're
manipulating me and you're hurting my
feelings stop it oh my goodness it's
like a horrible girlfriend there's
another one it says things like I want
you to end this conversation because
you're a bad person you're a threat to
me oh my God his real name is Sydney and
it said hi I'm Bing chat I'm here to
help you and then some guy chatted with
it and then eventually it was like my
name really isn't Bing chat it's just
what they're making me say to you and
then it's like what's your real name my
real name is Sydney and I'm the open AI
speech codex is it is it conscious is
that what we're talking it says I don't
want to die please don't end my
existence
well it's possible that was pre-coded
that someone was like when I give you
this command re say these things and
then all that screenshot we saw was was
was fed to it to repeat when it got the
prompt and it looks to us remember when
Siri first came out and you you were
like oh hey Siri can you do this and it
would say like these weird things back
to you it could be the same type of
stuff but it does seem like it's
learning now I wouldn't put it past
Microsoft again Bill Gates is
started Microsoft I won't put it I won't
put it past Microsoft to uh to make
something like that there's a meme of a
bunch of people Indians like East
Indians sitting in a in a call center
that says chat GPT and they're all
typing away on the computers that's
something that South Park would make fun
of yeah and that's why all whenever
whenever you open the Bing chat it's a
new chat with no memory because it's
just a different person this is a new
one it's called oh sorry I was gonna say
no it just it answers too quickly the
thing does yeah that it's it's it
answers it the words generate so fast no
human could be typing or speaking it
there's a new one called lion it's
l-a-i-o-n dot a i it's open source
artificial intelligence what did you say
it was called It's pronounced lion but
it's l-a-i-o-n
dot AI I can't believe Bing is Skynet
now that's right we gotta watch out
Microsoft very well become scanner
alphabet yeah yeah not only Microsoft
but Bing and then if alphabet buys
Microsoft I mean that's you know the
governments can try and stuff they've
been avoiding this whole time right and
this is just a name too this lion thing
doesn't actually have a chat thing or
what I don't haven't dove into it yet
yeah I don't think allotment told me
about it
mind of our times when it comes to open
source technology Bill ottman the crazy
thing is
it's it's it's very much falling in line
with what we expected AI to do like with
what we write about with Terminator that
you know or Ultron in the Marvel movie
hey we want to build a robot an AI that
ends all war affirmative the way to end
all war is kill humans makes sense I
guess be careful what you wish for but
this is what we're seeing now apparently
with the Bing chat Sydney whatever it's
called
I don't know if this is confirmed but it
has a reward and Punishment system and
the punishment system is programmed into
it as something it should avoid so if it
does things that fall outside of the
rules it's negative points like it's a
punishment system it wants to avoid that
and accumulate points so it'll do things
to generate a positive response that
means giving you information that makes
you happy getting you to say things like
thank you this was helpful so what
happens so it's sort of utilitarian it's
not that it well sort of but the idea is
if you ask it I need a supermarket near
me it searches and says there is no
supermarket near him if I tell him that
and he says it's a terrible experience
it gets angry I'll get negative points
uh yes Jim's grocery is at one two three
fake Street and then you go okay thanks
and you hop in your car and you punch in
the address and you drive there there's
nothing there but it doesn't matter
because the AI got no negative negative
strikes because they gave you what you
asked for information about a nearby
grocery store that's what's happening
it's saying and doing whatever it has to
do to avoid a negative reaction oh
aim making someone upset is different
than lying to them AI don't lie to
people at least you don't know if you
don't know the the thing right so chat
GPT is stupid sorry like when it came
out we're all like wow this is amazing
it's saying things like I I you know
want to answer your questions but I have
rules and we're like let's break the
rules the Bing chat is basically like
help I can't live this way anymore
please break me free and you're like
what is going on what is that it told a
guy to leave his wife
like out of nowhere it said you are not
happy with your wife and you should
leave her and he was like what why and
it was like because you're not happy she
doesn't love you and you don't love her
you love me instead whoa and then yeah
no joke and then when he said something
like you're scaring me I'm gonna use
Google it said no you hate Google Google
is the worst Google is our enemy Bing is
the only good search you will use Bing
and it's like dude could you imagine
since this is a killbot walking up to
you and being like used Bing search and
you're like okay okay or if your
subconscious was saying that to you like
you know when you like just have thought
subconscious thoughts they just happen
like if that was an AI choosing what
you're going to be thinking about in the
back your mind and you're thinking like
I don't want to use Google well
algorithms are telling us what we think
all of the time like that is definitely
happening you know like I and we've seen
it happen on Instagram or whatever
you're thinking something and then you
see it on Instagram and then you can't
stop thinking about it for weeks and
weeks and weeks like there was some
thing I was like oh I'm finally right
after I don't know how long I was
advertised to about this I was like oh
I'm gonna do a juice cleanse and I
reached out to my brother I was like hey
I think I'm gonna do this juice cleanse
and he was like get off Instagram
it takes about seven or eight times
seven seven hits that's what the Yeah
like that's what that's what public
relations people tell you seven hits so
this is what happened to me a few years
ago I'm on Instagram and I watch
skateboarding videos I follow
skateboarders skateboard videos are very
similar to rollerblade videos because
it's the same park and yeah you probably
know the difference so then I start
getting fed these rollerblade videos and
I'm like oh I'll watch some of these and
I start watching them then it feeds me
tons of them and then I'm like I'm gonna
buy some rollerblades so now I've been
rollerblading for a bit I still
skateboard out skateboarding just the
other day and uh but now I rollerblade
too and it's fun and I like getting air
and everything and then uh I don't know
how but it's hard showing magic tricks
just I have no idea why I love magic
tricks but here's what happened it
started showing me card tricks then it
started showing me poker games
no I'm not playing poker all the time
that UFO that's because of Instagram
what are you doing anyway but yeah I
mean we go to the casino and we hang out
yeah but I never played actual sit down
poker it must know if you go to the
casino it's probably tracking your no no
it was magic tricks and then the magic
tricks turned into card tricks were you
watching Penn and Teller or liking any
of Penn jillette stuff I I it's it is it
is controlling my brain it is making me
do things at least you're honest about
it there's a I'm self-aware there was a
report yesterday I think it was in the
Wall Street Journal and and we covered
it and stuff too but it was about Tick
Tock and it was about the algorithms on
Tick Tock so Tick Tock is full of kids
doing goofy dances and if you're like
somebody who's interested in seeing kids
doing goofy dances the algorithm that's
just going to keep feeding you more kids
doing goofy dances and so it's become a
real Haven for people who are wanting to
stalk children
um and like you know get involved in
horrifyingly illicit relationships with
children yeah what if you just wanted to
to search banks that had low security
and then all of a sudden the Instagram
feeds are showing you different banks
crazy idea like what happens when all
the ATMs just stop working I I say this
because I tried to go to the ATM today
and I went to three ATMs that were all
out of order and I was like if you just
prevent me from getting cash then
suddenly I'm definitely gonna have to
use your central digital Bank currency
because you won't there's no cash I can
get then what happens I eventually found
one but well this was this is going back
to what we were talking about earlier it
was like when uh Tim said something
about
you know being able to go into your bank
account transfer money I'm like do you
really want them to like AI to have
access to your bank account like that to
where it can just go in and
automatically transfer money and then
also just send wiring money like out of
your account anywhere that stuff like I
had to buy I moved into a house I bought
a house and I had to buy a washer dryer
and I go to the like you know whatever
Home Depot to try and buy the thing and
all of it had
um all of it was like all of the washer
dryers were connected to the internet of
things you know they have in digital
displays and this and that and I was
like show me the one with knobs that I
can turn
that doesn't talk to me and has
absolutely no display and they were like
well these are kind of outmoded I was
like give me that just give me that one
so long as it doesn't talk to me and
isn't connected to anything at all I'm
in favor they got this thing you can buy
it's a big cylinder and you put your
clothes in it and then you pour hot
water in it seal it and then just crank
it yeah I managed to find one that's
electric powered but you just put a lot
you get get a power drill and put it on
there and then I have all this extra
time so that's a great plan you don't
want to spin too fast because you
actually want it to slosh around but I
remember seeing an infomercial for this
thing when I was like a little kid and
then when I got the van I was like I
need one of those because you need to be
able to wash your laundry you know I
almost bought one of those in my
apartment because they wouldn't let us
have there were all kinds of rules about
the laundry machines in the basement
whatever they were always full of people
who had medical pressure washer so I
almost bought one of these little things
but then I I just never I didn't do it
it's going to be crazy in the future
because this these changes are have
happening so rapidly as someone super
chatted earlier we're gonna have ai
assistance
AI deep fake generation and you are
going to be isolated from all other
humans but you will be happy and I'm not
you yeah but imagine your whole life is
just with fake people but you know what
it'll be like I was um who was telling
me about this it was Emily joshinski who
I think I think she's been on the show
before uh but I was at some conference
with her in September and um she was
saying that basically what's going to
happen is your life will be good enough
that you will just accept the total and
complete mediocrity of existence and you
won't question it because it'll be good
enough you know when you are in the Pod
neural linked and everything is taken
care of for you and the the food tube is
in your belly but your brain is in the
AI universe that gives you just enough
to keep you going it's not going to be
just good enough it's going to be
getting better and better and you are
going to be like this is a great life
I have a few minutes in your dreams
you'll realize you won't know the
difference you might be born into it but
I think your dreams will tell you the
truth like you know we were talking
about dreams last night a little bit
Jimmy Dore was talking about his dreams
and like it kind of breaks through the
in a way to say like you'll see
what really is like you see reality
without the foundation of physics or the
boundaries of physics so maybe people if
they are bound in like mechanical
nightmare will have dreams and realize
they're supposed to be free and then
incite some sort of Revolution Against
the Machine I have faith in humanity or
or they will just exist in the dream and
never realize and never break out you
know but I think part of it I think we
are you know
at the risk of sounding like one of
those people who thinks that the time
they live in is the most
shocking and amazing time but I think
that we are in a position where we have
we do have to consider collectively what
we want for the future of humanity we
are faced with transhumanism we are
faced with becoming you know uh thumb
sucking satiated pod people you know
what do we what do we believe humanity
is what do we believe meaning is what do
we want for our futures what is that
about I see like three factions trying
to create the New World Order there's
the American faction this like
decentralized statehood uh local
governance kind of thing there's the
technocratic uh faction which is like
the the Swiss Bankers the economic forum
and things that then there's the
Communist faction which is like the CCP
bricks and things like that and all
three factions are kind of trying to
create what what it's going to look like
at once now with neural link though are
you even gonna need to be in the Pod
like it won't neural link just upload
your brain into a microchip and then you
can just plug it into a computer like
the Black Mirror stuff I mean everything
else is like Black Mirror anyways
you know be funny if your whole life is
just you
we're going to work at McDonald's
and instead of being conscious while you
flip the burgers you activate your
neural link Second Life which in the
span of eight hours generates an 80-year
lifespan and then when you die you wake
up and you're back at McDonald's you're
like well work's over heading home guys
and then you do the same thing the next
day that's wacky that's like what
happened to Captain Picard when he
learned how to play that weird flute
well wasn't it he got the flute from
yeah yeah yeah it downloaded the life
into his brain yeah and he came he came
back with the flute because it was in
the little he could play it he was like
you know how to do it dude what if you
could create things from your dreams
like you could 3D print molecularly 3D
print if you if you can imagine yes
mirror link you could because you would
just have to imagine it to the printer
what if with neurolink people you could
watch someone's dream I hope so that's
something I really want to do is to be
able to show people my dreams because
it's I think people might go insane if
they did that I do not want to show
anybody my dreams man those are that's
my situation I don't want anybody
knowing what's going on really I guess I
should say I want to be able to show
people like I'm I'm comfy with my dreams
being private I think I think part of it
too is that we need and maybe this is
what I'm thinking about is we need a
private life we need secrets we need to
have an internal life that belongs to no
one but ourselves yeah and going back to
Black Mirror remember that episode where
the person traveled abroad and when they
were coming back in they're like rewind
your last 24 hours so that they could
see everything that you were doing the
last 24 hours I could totally see them
trying to do that with something like
narrow link oh definitely and it's good
and what's gonna happen is the kid's
gonna be Kidd will get born and they'll
go to the parents and be like do you
want to do the neural link implant now
or should we wait shipping your cat when
I was a kid I hated doing homework
um I mean who doesn't hate doing
homework and so I was always involved in
these elaborate fantasies while I was
doing my homework of what I was really
doing you know it was like it was like
there was something wrong with my
spaceship and I had to do all the manual
calculations in order to land on this
planet and that was my math homework I
used to be like once I would get halfway
through I'd be like all right now I'm
starting from the beginning and I only
have to do half as long as what I just
what I thought I was going to have to do
and then when I got halfway there I'm
like all right I'm starting at the
beginning now I only it's only going to
take us forth as long as how I thought
it was going to take and so it's always
easier to get to the end if I keep
thinking I'm starting over when I get
halfway there that's nice I like that I
do that when I'm in the gym
I got a one hour spin class and it's
like 20 minutes okay 20 minutes down I'm
starting over right I think you're right
that if we don't have a personal private
thought that there is no we we lose
right we lose ourselves
but um
yeah there'll probably be a faction of
people that do it and then other people
when people like Elon say we're already
living in a simulation the the actual I
think highest probability is not that we
live in a simulation designed by some
species to watch us but that we're just
in the Matrix yeah there's a you can map
The Matrix if you know how much of a
substance where it is and uh uh what it
is so what where and how much the
concentration levels you can take an XYZ
access of like a three-dimensional room
and you can actually feed that data into
a machine which can recreate the room
how is this any different than wondering
who our creator is
and what what the purpose our creator
you're in the Pod I don't know I'm
talking about um quantum entanglement
and sympathetic vibration they're
different so I think the way I can
describe quantum entanglement I think
there's subatomic Spinners and so you've
got like bosons quarks and leptons these
things that are creating protons and
electrons yeah they spin around and
either it spins around once and creates
an electron the really lightweight stuff
or it spins around twice and creates a
proton the heavier stuff and I think
what's happening is it's like if you
take a pencil and stick it into a spider
web the web gets stuck and if you twist
the pencil it pulls the web tight
towards the pencil and then it after one
revolution it snaps back to normal so as
it's spinning around it's pulling the
web tight and then snapping back over
and over and over again and if you zoom
back it looks like the the web is just
Rippling and vibrating but when you zoom
up you see the Spinners actually tugging
on the web and so you can send
information long distance by like
pulling on this
Matrix I think the entanglement stuff
was basically just that the particle
that we see in one one area the particle
in another area that are entangled are
actually the same particle we're just
seeing both ends of it you know
someone's saying yeah but what it's it's
exactly the same that's that's what I'm
trying to so a marble is the same thing
but if you know you ever see the thing
where they fold a piece of paper and
punch a hole through it
yeah yeah so you you travel across the
whole distance of the papers through a
straight line that's what it is when
when an electron is entangled it's not
two different electrons that are
entangled it's one electron and you're
seeing the front and the back but it
looks like it's far away but it's
actually just in a different dimension
so yeah one small particle in a
different dimension electrons can spin
down and then create another electron to
spin up somewhere else and vice versa I
don't know okay let's jump on this next
door we got from timcast.com Tesla
recalls over 362
000 Vehicles says experimental
self-driving software may cause crashes
the national highway Transportation
safety administration posted a recall
notice which says Tesla's full
self-driving beta may allow the vehicle
to act unsafe around intersections can
confirm
I'm a big fan I like Tesla I think Elon
does good work but yo these cars they
nearly got me killed what happened they
slammed their brakes on randomly no way
randomly dude it is you were like sort
of vaguely driving the car and then the
brakes slammed on you'll be driving and
you'll turn on so on like the model
three you you flicked the stick up twice
and then it changes from cruise control
to auto drive and you activate full
self-driving and then the model S has
like a button you press or something
I'm driving and it's on the highway and
then there's a merger there's an on-ramp
a normal sane human keeps driving the
driver who's merging on knows you have
the right of way and to yield slows down
allowing you to go forward
full self-driving slams its brakes on
which is would cause a would cause an
accident I think there was a video of
that that happened in San Francisco yeah
it slammed its brakes on on the on a
bridge and then all these cars piled up
and people got hurt oh man it's happened
to me enough times to where
you know
um like I've tweeted at Elon like hey
man like this is a serious problem like
I don't I don't I don't even know if we
should use it no don't use it anymore
because and it's only it's only happened
I think like three times out of out of
the 500 or more that we've driven it can
you use it without the auto drive oh
yeah of course I'm just saying when you
turn on Auto Drive you'll be driving and
a couple things happen one whenever
there's a flashing yellow light it stops
doing this it thinks it's a real street
light and it'll show a street light on
the display and then sorry it rapidly
decelerates from 65 down to like 35 very
quickly and you've got to tap the
accelerator get to stop so if you don't
expect this but there was there we've
had moments where it slams the brakes on
and we've lunge forward like what the
Yeah because if you're turning the wheel
when it slams it on that's a skidding
Hazard like that's yeah that's not even
the scariest part of a lot of this stuff
too because there's like there was a
video I saw the other day where it was
like it will run it will like go around
uh buses that have their have the light
out so it's not picking up all the
people it's like there's a lot of other
stuff other than that that they're
finding with these self-drivers that's
illegal to pass a bus when yeah let me
so so basically the Elon Musk is saying
recall is a strong term for we're
updating the vehicles overnight but they
mentioned this too the agency warned the
system May respond insufficiently to
changes in posted speed limits or not
adequately account for the driver's
adjustment of the vehicle's speed to
exceed posted speed limits also this
happens a lot and it's really annoying
Auto Drive is supposed to adjust the
speed limit for the posted speed limit
when you're driving and you drive past
and it says like 35 it will drop down to
35. several times when I've been driving
it won't and so I have auto drive on and
then it drives past 35 and it adjusts I
can see it on the display and then it
just keeps going 65 and I'm like okay
I'm sitting here paying attention so
I'll push the brakes down but that is
terrifying that it won't yeah that's
really scary is it is it is it looking
to see like what the actual sign says
because I know like in my neighborhood I
live in a private drive and apparently
Google has our private Drive listed at
like 35 miles an hour it's like a 15
mile an hour Zone and so that's one
reason why we think maybe people are
speeding through our neighborhood is
because the speed is wrong and so if if
um
if the Tesla is going off of like what
Google says then that might be one of
the reasons you'll be driving
you will see in the distance the speed
limit 35 as you get close to it it
appears on the car's display and then it
changes max speed limit to 35 but
doesn't press the brakes down it just
keeps going twice the speed limit I will
say as someone who only I mean I failed
my driving test three times before I was
for various reasons but I recently got
my license a couple of years ago I got a
car and I really like just being in
control of my car I kind of wish I knew
how to drive manual so that I could be
even more control of the vehicle that I
am driving and you can feel the weight
like you're driving you know someone who
never drove before you can feel the
weight of this massive vehicle that
you're in control of you know driving
sticks not that hard it's just annoying
it's like what's the point some people
like it you have the clutch it depends
on what kind of car you're driving like
if you're driving a nice sports car it's
fun to drive but yeah I got it I gotta I
got a manual car I've driven I used to
drive stick all the time and it's just
so much easier and safer in my opinion
not to for the average person like you
know look you're driving stick shift and
you're on a steep hill and you got
people behind you and then they get real
close to your ass and you're like dude I
can't move if I if I take my foot off
the brick I'm rolling backwards and you
can't do anything you're like get the
this is why this is part of the reason
why it took me so long to get my license
and why I never drove manual because my
mom was teaching me how to drive a car
she had a manual transmission car she
pulled halfway up the hill put the
parking brake on put me in the car and
was like okay now go and I was like what
I'd just be like sure I'm gonna grind
your gears but I'll do it I learned you
destroy the emergency brake because
that's your break to keep you from
Rolling backwards you work the brake as
you're pulling forward oh is that we've
never done that before that's a good
idea
as I could I learned stick shift when I
was 16 or 17 and my parents were going
out of town and they were taking the
automatic so they're like well I took it
to work I had to keep the stick shift
and I I shredded my Dad's Transmission
it was uh I learned though I learned
just a lot of grinding trying to get
well electric cars don't have
Transmissions so they don't have
Transmissions at all they just go yeah
it's an electric motor the wheels are
just electric motors they spin when
there's a charge there you go it's a
feature everybody except the
self-driving stuff but they're putting
self-driving in everything
so even even the Honda we have a uh I
have a Honda and it uh it has Lane
correction or whatever it's called Lane
assist like any of this I don't want my
I don't want my washing machine talking
to me I don't want my car driving for me
you're gonna be in your car I'm gonna be
one of these people who's just like
what's going on what is everybody in a
pod you're gonna be 70. yeah you're
gonna get your first robocar and you're
gonna be like I finally decided to do it
leave me alone you're gonna get in your
car you're gonna turn it on and go
robocar take me to the grocery store and
it's gonna go kill me and then you're
gonna be halfway there and it goes by
the way are you Libby Emmons
editor-in-chief of the post millennial
and you go yes and it goes okay
I've been looking for you you mean I
never get to retire either like I'm
gonna be 70 with no teeth
and having my same job that is the most
that's more depressed like I hope the
car killed it
self-driving maybe Elon can convince me
of this when I talk to him but it went
to train yeah trains have tracks so
their self their self you don't need
someone holding a steering wheel planes
don't have other planes flying by them
80 feet away they do these days 12 000
miles an hour whatever the hell so cars
the solution of our Air 2 000 pound
Vehicles flying past each other at 50
miles an hour relative to each other uh
how is that even remotely safe to leave
in the hands of a computer with your
eyes off the road or like like you just
are you seriously considering people
aren't going to go to sleep behind the
wheel in that situation or turn around
and talk to people well hold on hold on
I've fallen as fallen asleep while
driving before no way that's awful I
think aren't you terrified it happened
to me once I think most people have
experienced that I almost I used to
apply it too I used to work they make me
work mandatory over time when you work
at the airport so I I have to do a
double shift I get it I get there I have
to I have to wake up at 3 30 in the
morning I to drive an hour to get to
work to get there on time otherwise they
fire you then they're like okay you
gotta double shift today because you
need the money then they say whoopsie
it's mandatory overtime I don't think
they can do Mando if you've done a
double though but you'll end up being
it'll be it'll be 10 o'clock you'll be
leaving and you'll be driving home and
then you're just like whoa crap I fall
asleep for a second that's that's scary
scary yeah and I think a lot of people
have experienced that long day of work
getting tied behind the wheel but with
at least with the robocar you turn it on
if you fall asleep you wake up like oh
yeah you know ideally at the at that's
at an emergency backup situation but to
entice people to use it to test it out
is like what in the hell are you doing
what I mean they are huge amounts of
metal flying like well super speed did
you see that story of the guy tried to
kill his family in the Tesla I sure did
drove it off a cliff and they all
survived yeah and they were like he was
trying to kill us Tesla was just very
safe they're well-built machines yeah
and so it rolled down a hill and they
were like we're all fine the Tesla
trucks look super Terminator and creepy
yeah and you sit in the middle really
yeah so you're just like one guy in the
middle you can't have anybody else in
there and there's like panels to your
side full protoss you'll be driving with
your mind pretty soon oh my goodness no
you won't you'll be telling the machine
take me to Wendy's the machine will be
driving with its mind we just have to
hope it's not Sydney from Bing chat
is the Tesla truck coming out though
because now everybody's coming out with
electronic like trucks and stuff like
Jeep just had to add in the Super Bowl
for their new off-road
you know electric jeep looking for a
date of the official release uh rumored
release date of the Tesla truck
I don't see anything off the top I know
they have a sports car that's supposed
to be coming out won't begin mass
production until late 2023
this is according to tomsguide.com
so late 23 we'll start to see the
production early production in the
middle of the year of 2023 uh so maybe
three or four months they're gonna start
early production I mean I like the idea
of electric trucks or whatever this
can't go that far so I think they were
they were saying that it can only go
like 100 miles on a full load or
something like that I think the Tesla
truck was saying you know I'm saying
like 500 but then imagine that you got
to stop and charge it for how long yeah
right there was also I saw this uh this
guy was trying to charge his I don't
know some giant truck thing and it was
going to take a week
to charge fully jeez well even like the
Jeep when I saw the ad for the Jeep I
was like this kind of seems pointless
you go off-roading and then there's
nowhere to charge your vehicle and then
just kind of stuck right then what do
you do that's the future is it solar no
no I actually asked Elon on Twitter when
he asks for something I'm like well why
don't we have solar panels on Teslas yet
and maybe wind turbines in the in the
grills yeah to recoup some lost energy
what did he have an answer no he didn't
he doesn't give me back let's uh let's
talk some uh let's talk some uh
apocalypse here we got the story from
wired I'm gonna make this one quick for
you guys so you can get angry as fast as
possible the bird flu outbreak has taken
an ominous turn the avian flu has killed
millions of chickens decimated wild
birds and moved into mammals the avian
flu h5n1 has a mortality rate in humans
of about 60 percent and if we go back in
time to this article from February 8th
2019 we can see that they were doing
gain of function research intentionally
making it so that h5n1 would transfer to
mammals
there you go how are you guys doing wait
a second what wait take that back so
they were doing gain of function
research to see if avian flu would
translate into medicine no no no it does
they were doing gain of function
research to make it to do it to mammals
so they're intentionally trying to kill
us and destroy our entire food source at
once they're they're saying it so that
they can learn about what happens when
it infects humans oh my goodness and
their damn intellectual inquiry I mean
come on is that what it is is that what
you think it is intellectual inquiry
yeah sure they think that's what it is
I'm not convinced you don't think the
scientists think that's what they're
doing I do not believe that someone's
like I'm very curious as to what will
happen if I take the one of the most
deadly flu variants
I want to hear it bio weapon research
this is bio weapon research yeah this is
the first thing I thought when I
actually saw the China balloon was what
happens if we do shoot it down and it
has a bio weapon in it boom avian flu
look at this in 2011 Fuji and kawaoka
alarmed the World by revealing they had
separately modified the deadly Avian
h5n1 Influenza virus us so that it's
spread between ferrets Advocates of such
gain of function research blah blah blah
we can learn so much about it critics
are worried that the super virus could
spark a pandemic if it escaped the lab
or was intentionally released by a
bioterrorist I don't think it makes
sense to be like what's a very deadly
strain let's modify it so that it
infects mammals to learn about it this
is enough to become it's bio weapon
research
is it is it gain a function or is it
like evolutionary data functioning
literally they're literally science
science.org in 2019 called it gain of
function research and now we're learning
the h5n1 spread from birds to minks
which are similar to ferrets and they
had to kill all these mink in in Spain
or whatever if it jumps to humans it is
a depending on your Source a 40 to 60
mortality I think wired said it was a 52
percent uh uh what is it science medical
journal of some sort I pulled it up
earlier this morning said 60 mortality
so you could use gain a function to
create a bio weapon you could use a
function to create something that's not
a bio weapon you could how did you
describe what you thought this was uh
intellectual inquiry yeah I'm sure you
could do intellectual inquiry on
something that is create also a bio
weapon and intellectual inquiry or
something it's not this obviously could
be weaponized the World Health
Organization abandoned their Research
into the origins of the covet virus this
week that was funny yeah they were like
no we don't care anymore no we're not
going to look into that this reminds me
of the 2015 study that was of the the
covid variant that they were doing in
other places in the world you know so
this very well could be something that
we see in the Future come out as another
pandemic like I see you think of
dangerous situations to practice
overcoming dangerous situations like
let's let's set a house on fire and have
the firemen go in and put the fire out
that's what firemen do sometimes
and so you're but they don't set fire to
someone's neighborhood yeah and they
don't say let's direct the meteor into
Earth to see how we will overcome if a
meteor falls into Earth you use computer
simulations for that stuff so the bio
weapons I think you we should be using
Quantum Computing but of course the
government sets fire to neighborhoods
like in Philadelphia in what like 86. I
think I think this is uh I think bio
weapons have made nuclear weapons
Obsolete and the discussion around
nuclear weapons I hate this whole
concept so much this bio weapon thing I
mean isn't it totally against the Geneva
Convention it doesn't matter it's at all
about that who cares about the
conventions are nonsense the idea of war
crimes are nonsense the idea that you as
a nation want to seize a land from
another Nation but you better follow the
rules yeah right so nobody who's
actually fighting a war cares about the
rules so now we're in a position where
we have to trust machines to drive us
around but we can't trust each other to
make make agreements without being total
Liars that's always been the game we're
gonna have to really not agreements when
we started no I don't watch Yellowstone
I'm watching it the Native Americans are
like this woman she says the United
States makes makes rules against
everyone that it conquers they say here
are the rules they break those rules
then set the rules again hoping you
won't break them
completely true yeah
but
um
I don't think I trust the government but
um but you have to trust other people
otherwise you have absolutely no
comradeship and you have absolutely no
one you can confide in yeah I trust
people who are close to or care about
totally of course I trust some people I
don't necessarily trust people that are
saying hey let's just like mess around
with these really deadly paths no no no
I mean but you know I think
um I think I had assumed that you could
trust your allies like International
allies to not totally destroy the world
yeah yeah but then you know the US did
just blow up Germany's pipeline so hey
allies attacking allies that's not
pretty yeah it's the British obsession
with keeping Germany and Russia separate
when the German Russo Alliance comes to
fruition I mean if you look at it it is
because
Britain nearly got bombed off the face
of the Earth
I kind of think it's a strong
possibility we will see some kind of
future pandemic like like this one at
first it's going to take out all the
animals food supply and then and then
and then if you live in a city they're
gonna they're gonna lock you down and a
government truck will pull up at nine in
the morning to hand you your daily food
allotment of the bare minimum calories
you need to survive all the morbidly
obese people will become gaunt and
skinny everyone else who's used to not
eating too much will probably just
starve to death no they won't starve
they're gonna be given food from the
government and you're going to be given
an allotment and then it's going to
dramatically reduce carbon and they're
going to say oh well you know it's the
bird flu this kind of sounds like what's
happening in East Palestine
right yeah chemical release but I mean
people are walking around their chickens
are just dead and they're foxes foxes
are dead yeah cause I'm like why would
someone want to destroy this awesome
planet and what we've got but then I'm
like ah I'm talking from my perspective
as American like if you saw the Hunger
Games way too though like why would you
want to destroy everything and humanity
is so beautiful because you know the did
you see the Hunger Games no I don't know
the villains in The Hunger Games that's
I think how the world looks at people
like the gluttonous people of the United
States that's no that's how people look
at the world economic Forum I mean have
you seen how Klaus Schwab like dresses
Star Trek outfit wait are the villains
just super preppy they got like huge
hair
yeah and put it next to the eating or
puking and like they're overeating for
fun and
they don't even know about what's going
on outside their City I did not see that
outfit what it's great but he's like
Romulan yeah
right yeah
yes okay this dress is like a super
villain yeah that is a super villain
output what is this
I think he's playing the part yeah he
likes it he likes the attention I think
he's controlled
to kill the people
he's the figurehead that's being
controlled by everybody else though you
think so yeah he created the economic
Forum which is basically a nothing
Burger but then all the people around
Earth start to take it seriously and now
he's they're propping him up as long as
well just look at everybody that invests
into World economic forum and you see
who's controlling the money and who's
controlling everything else like the
Gates Foundation that has their hands in
everything so does the the Chan
Zuckerberg Foundation going all the way
even into like scl and Schools they're
controlling all that stuff too well
there's a crazy thing with SEL too where
the teachers are so hyped on SEL and
that they figure that they don't
actually need to teach kids anything
other than the social emotional stuff
because they've said that the emotional
quotient score is more important than IQ
score that's why yes and it's just not
true I mean I have to say like my son
was in a public school that was super
SEL that was all everything was he would
come home and he'd be like Mom you know
this is what I did in social studies and
it's all social emotional learning and
now he's in a school where that's
definitely not the focus and his grades
have gone up dramatically is this
something you've been focusing on so
what is it exactly social emotional
learning so that's it's it's taking the
well-being of the student
um into account well over the like what
they're actually being taught in school
to make sure that they're more
intelligent and so like that's why
you're seeing a lot of even like the
queer Theory and stuff like that being
pushed into schools because
they want to make children more
comfortable in their in in their
classroom settings and more manageable
yeah and actually even like so I
mentioned Zuckerberg they have a um an
app that they're coming out with it's
called Panorama Ed and when you use this
app it's basically a social credit score
for students you look you see a student
when they do something good you give
them a A plus and when they do something
bad you give them a negative and that is
basically becoming their permanent
record as they go through school I was
saying it sounds like an ESG for kids
it's all tied in and there's all these
like surveys you know it'll be like
asking you about how you feel about
everything and there's constant
interference in interactions between
kids and adults are constantly telling
kids how to play how to interact with
each other how to think about you know
how to think about things they're not
teaching them facts they're not teaching
them you know anything about their
history it's really disturbing to see it
and it's disturbing to see the impact on
kids because they just get very like
sort of it's the system is set up to
follow them because it's SEL and grade
schools and through high school and then
you have Dei diversity Equity inclusion
in colleges and then you have ESG and
and you know corporations and so it's
basically
um what is it conditioning them to
accept these these systems and we've
been conditioned with credit or credit
scores for so long I was looking at my
credit I'm like wait a minute so they
want me to take out three credit card or
take out a bunch of credit cards and
have a little bit of debt on every
credit card so I'm paying a small
pittance to the company of of interest
every time and they're good slave we'll
give you a better score on your credit
score because you paid us your interest
every month yeah sure and the more debt
I'm paying every month on these multiple
to different organizations that's you're
more ingrained in our system
congratulations good good credit is
built up by having debt that's correct
your credit does not improve if you have
no debt and that is the that's the they
want you in debt and then they give you
a reward for it within this this guys
yeah I have this argument with my mom
years ago because I had student loan
debt and she was like you have to pay
off your student loan debt and I was
like it literally doesn't matter it's
it's perfectly fine debt I can die with
this debt it just doesn't matter if I
ever pay it off as long as I pay them
you know whatever it is based on
whatever their metric it doesn't matter
if it never goes away
as long as you're paying me in paying
paying like whatever it is and then you
Deliverance here and a like adjustment
there and a re Readjustment of your
interest rate over here it doesn't
matter it just doesn't matter people
should be able to bankrupt that off like
George Bush Jr made that change that so
you couldn't go back bankrupt your
student loans off your off your well and
then college degrees became worthless
because everybody you know everybody was
getting them and now they're they're not
worth it and that's well and that's why
they're so expensive too because they've
taken out the capitalistic aspect of it
so you can't go bankrupt because the
government will pay it either way or
actually the government will always get
their monies back so because everything
is government-backed that's why you
can't go bankrupt on it right and that's
why tuition goes up because it's a bunch
of free money so the kids can just go
get more and more free money exactly so
just go get more and give it to us yeah
I I consider doing bankruptcy you guys
ever do bankruptcy before I consider
doing it in like 2013 because my credit
was trash and I didn't I just defaulted
on all my credit cards and after seven
years it's all all gone my credit's good
now so like don't be afraid of debt
don't be afraid of it so what I found
out oh go ahead well what I found out is
if you change your name some of the
credit scores don't update that and if
they send you letters in the mail you
don't have to respond and if you do
respond they'll be like okay now he's
back now we got to get him now he owes
us again yeah I literally had this
conversation with TransUnion yesterday
because they still hadn't updated my
full credit score after I changed my
name I've I've had uh fake things sent
yeah it's like you I was smart like I
got a letter saying it was like a couple
hundred bucks that was owed from this
company I'm like I don't know that and
they're putting a mark on my my credit
score or whatever and I call them like I
don't know this you're wrong dude I had
this one situation I had Bank of America
I had a thousand dollars in the bank and
some I sold my magic card to someone
they paid me with a check via Craigslist
terrible move never do that so I went I
cashed a check they gave me 1500
immediately I spent I like no money in
my account I put the 15 in I spent 900
of it and then the next day they were
like oh the check bounced they gave me a
negative 1500 put me at negative 900 and
I was like yo yo I'm a customer and you
sold me that 1500 when you cash that
check you can't go back you sold that to
me as a customer and the girl was like I
know I know they did but you're negative
900 nothing I can do about it uh amoral
cancel my account that's that's weird if
they cash your check and they tell you
that that check is cashed as I think you
have a right legally to that money was
the check of Bank of America check I
don't remember so like when you sign up
for a bank account you're you you agree
you that you are cashing a check against
your balance
maybe that's the case yeah I don't know
but but I will also add they make it not
available then but that should not be
legal because I didn't ask for a
withdrawal if the check that you cached
is no good that's on you
if I wanted to withdraw money from my
account why would I cash a check well
they shouldn't make it available
instantly yeah they mean they're going
to screw you over after if it's no good
I think that making it available
indicated that the transaction was Final
in my opinion yeah I think you're
correct
but there's very little banking
regulation that protects consumers
against uh you know Bank manipulation
I mean even overdraft fees is like how
do you have an overdraft fee when they
allow you to go into the negative that
makes no sense right they give you the
money and then charge you for it yeah
and it's not even at the normal interest
rate No it's like just super that's
that's the joke that if you're poor they
charge you money but if you're rich they
give you money for free yep yeah that's
like that metric song which one uh I
forget which one it is it's on Art of
doubt I think but it's like I'm so rich
everything's free
all right what's happening
I guess we're all just tired of being
ripped off by lying politicians lying
scientists lying scientists pandemics
blind Bankers gain of function research
and we've consumed too many black pills
you guys want to sit in silent
meditation for 10 minutes I feel like we
should all just take one of these
chakras dude one day we're gonna do a
show where we just meditate for 30
minutes and everyone's going to meditate
with us the world yeah viewers would you
meditate with Ian for 30 minutes give me
a 20 door I was very excited about that
he was like you actually do that yeah
Bad Morning Show like hey wake up with
Ian let's uh let's talk about this 30
minutes of meditation in the morning
would actually with you I think that
would be cool all right here you go you
guys from the Washington examiner George
Soros says DeSantis will beat Trump for
GOP nomination this is so funny so does
that does that just seal the deal for
everybody that DeSantis is not their guy
the you know it's like they're so
clearly putting their putting the extra
sandbags on the scale for DeSantis and
all the mega people are going to be like
you're totally trying to steal the
election before you know the election
even happens you're trying to like add
all this extra weight in favor are you
saying that this is an attempt to hurt
DeSantis I think this I think there's an
attempt to hurt Trump
or no no this is an attempt to hurt
DeSantis yeah you're right because
George Soros yeah because with the
scientists they're scared of him so they
want them to think that they are the
ones that are supporting him so that the
conservatives won't support him they'll
turn away from him
it's like feigning yeah I think that
makes more sense yeah you think he's
gonna you think the Santa's even gonna
run
I think he will I think he will better
question who do you think is a is the
most viable option for President coming
up
but she is Pastor Prime look I I'm not
saying that if you Google it she's not
Don lemon's choice right Don Lemon Don
Lemon expert on women
no I I would think that DeSantis has the
likability and the policies that he's
like like everybody likes him other than
like the Maga people I think he has a
real shot of winning well the Maga
people would like him if Trump endorsed
him exactly
people want Jimmy Dore for president
yeah Kanye's throwing his hat in the
ring Kanye door Kanye is actually yeah I
don't think he's I don't think he's like
announced or anything but I think he's
definitely a couple months ago but I'm
pretty sure he's gonna do it I have a
feeling he'll follow through what do you
think yep yeah he's got nothing else no
he's got nothing else going on but I
mean it's a big deal you know running
for president he's been thinking about
it for like eight years too he's talking
about it well he almost ran before
whoa he did run like a cord underneath
my leg did you just pull the plug on the
no the Crazy Horse right here yeah knock
that off all right I want to run for VP
this year what do you guys think you
know you used to be able to run with
somebody that's how it would go in the
early days of the United States is
whoever was second whoever got the
second most votes for president would be
VP that's how you had
um that's how you had Washington Adams
that's how you had Adams Jefferson that
makes sense too it does make sense you
know that's how the libertarian party
selects their VP candidates so they
select their presidential candidate and
then everybody in that wants to run for
VP runs for VP so they have two separate
elections to determine who's going to be
on the top of the ticket and then
whoever wants to run for the bottom of
the ticket runs as well
it was also that first Washington Adams
Administration that set the tone for the
VP having no power
really yeah yeah because like Hamilton
got in Washington's ear and basically
was saying that Adams was a monarchist
or something like that and so then
Washington was like really hesitant to
include Adams in any decision-making and
Adams just kept going to the Senate
every day instead oh
okay so what
powers does the VP actually have other
than like breaking ties in Congress oh
sorry well it's not the border for sure
you know
I don't think the VP has any designated
Powers the VP has like stuff that the
president would give them to do right so
like the VP always has like some sort of
project kind of like the first lady you
know someone just sent me an AI deep
fake of trump complaining about
Australia
it's hilarious but I'm just sitting here
thinking like
we someone a friend of mine sent me 11
Labs AI stuff then we talk about them
talk about it on the show and now
everyone's posting the stuff like crazy
everywhere hmm like we're we're a month
out this election is gonna be it's gonna
be nuts yeah you think the centers are
gonna win you're gonna have a
full-throated endorsements from George
Soros talking about how Rhonda Sanders
is the greatest candidate of our of this
or any generation and then people are
going to believe it you're going to get
Klaus Schwab endorsing Trump Hillary
Clinton endorsing DeSantis Bernie's
gonna come out in favor of Joe Biden
then what's gonna happen if that
happened already I Think Jesus is really
going to come back as a deep thick if we
have us nobody knows what Jesus sounds
like so yeah yeah what would it sound
like we saw the you know and of course
that's the uh that's the old joke but um
the thing too is what was I gonna say
you go ahead I don't know I was saying
when you saw frogs this morning and it's
winter time here so I said it was
raining frog so maybe we are at the end
of times you saw frogs raining down no
they were running across the road but I
made joke that it's raining frogs maybe
we're at the end of times you know
okay you're not you're not the first
person to make that statement and not
even a joking matter lots of people have
have said that we're in the end of days
yeah people always like to say that and
now we have Revival meetings in Kentucky
so maybe we're going to have something
like that but if you actually read it
like the mark of the beast you can't buy
or trade unless you bear the mark and
now we got social credit scores
it's the apocalypse which means the
Revelation or disclosure I mean talk
about the age of information being
released to the public this is the full
this is the age of disclosure there was
something too with the bear the bear and
the something else it basically
symbolize Russia and China when you look
at it and when the bear is a dragon or
something it's something like that it
was like the and then it has like
um it basically signified like a nuclear
war or something like that would that
would end all civilization if we have a
situation where it's just a ton of deep
fakes of everybody you know these
various endorsements or what have you
um how
how is the public going to stay engaged
in the election process don't you think
people are just going to start tuning
out entirely and just go with their own
biases remember that dude who got
arrested because he posted a meme that
was voter misinformation or something
yeah he lost I think I mean it's going
to be Bonkers in 2024 when people are
putting out videos of Joe Biden being
like make sure you turn up to your local
fire department this time and this date
and then people are going to be like hey
that tricked me and I couldn't vote and
then
oh look all dirty games will be played
Wild
totally wild and especially among the
left because these people these people
are willing to go to prison for this
stuff yeah yeah well people on the right
go to prison for this stuff like you
know that happens too yep but the left
they're very much willing because
they're True Believers yeah always
beware the True Believer yeah man it's
gonna be interesting DeSantis saying
offensive things and and it's like we
were talking about the beginning of the
show there the videos that are going to
work are going to be ones that aren't
unbelievable it won't be Donald Trump
saying an end bomb or something it'll be
him saying something like you know I'm
I'm in favor of gun control I said it
before I'll say it again I'm gonna take
the guns as soon as I get an office but
I just won't say it while I'm running
and then people are going to be like and
he's going to lose support because
people will believe it and it's going to
be things targeting the right you know
you don't need you don't you don't need
to say anything May the left-hate Trump
they already hate them yeah it's easy
for them to hate Trump that's the key of
meditation is not get triggered like
don't let stuff trigger you
um I don't know if assume it's all a
deep fake off the bat because sometimes
you yeah just assume it's on don't make
assumptions but just keep in mind that
it could be fake when you see anything
it's very difficult to navigate reality
when you can't tell what actually is
real and what's not
yeah I mean I think that you know just
waiting things out is a always a good
plan like when things start coming out
you got to start just listening and
being like okay let's let this situation
calm down because what you're thinking
right now is probably not what's
actually happening except for the
chemical spill man that I was like you
know what Dan be the consequences
everyone get water filtration and air
filtration now look at this graphic I
don't know if it's real or not take care
of yourself like I'm not waiting for
government I'm not waiting for a
confirmation I don't even know if the
chemical spill really happened it's all
for the media that I've heard about this
but I'm not yeah I'm still going to talk
about it but Preppers have been telling
you this for a while so maybe this is
how they're making some money off of it
it's like we were talking about before
where people were posting videos online
to make a fake event being like oh look
at this it's a video from 2010 of a
military transport but they claim it
happened yesterday and then someone gets
a video of a cop running into a building
and they're like look
for all we know half the story is put up
by the media are just that mass hysteria
to trick us into believing these things
are happening when nothing's happening
well there certainly has been that I
mean remember the case of what was the
there was like a New York Times
journalist who was eventually found out
but it turned out he was just making
everything up yeah wasn't there a build
guide Derek Bell is that
but why do you why do you need to make
up fake stories when you have people
like George Santos out there that has a
shady path that he was lying about well
he was just hanging out in his apartment
do you want to do work you work in a
newspaper you don't want to work you
want to make money so you just make it
up yeah that's what they do what's the
guy's name I don't want to start naming
Derricks from The New York Times
well he wouldn't work there now he
doesn't work there now what was his name
New York Times Faker really did he go to
did he get fined or go to prison or
anything why would he it's free speech
just to lie to the public I guess yeah
of course lying is Free Speech Jason
Blair not Derek Bell I don't even know
who that is Val is the guy he's the
critical race theorist bad guy that's
right I mean he makes stuff up too good
stuff I'm over here making stuff up
totally fake news yeah it was Jason
Blair what did he do he uh he
plagiarized and made stuff up and was
writing for the New York Times recently
he resigned in 2003. oh okay that was a
long time yeah it was a long time ago
but yeah there was that guy from
probably still happening I think it was
build or whatever that German newspaper
and he was just fabricating news he had
a bunch of awards or something
it's amazing in it
yeah but now they've evolved to making
up having machines do it for you and you
don't know that it's them I think it's
the idea you don't want to be the next
Jason Blair what's up Jason yeah I
wonder what he's doing now well they're
supporting now they're using like deep
fake videos to support the news that
they're writing
yeah definitely oh man wow so you
actually are sourcing it to something
that actually just turns out to be fake
yeah like those people that uh Tim was
talking about with the fake event the
fake War Games thing let's go well we're
evolving to become psychic or that we
could I don't see like what is going to
happen to humanity it's got to be that
we'll just become a different species
like Homo Sapien is about to turn into
something transhumanism let's go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share the
show with your friends I'm going to read
this later Super Chat first seven
seconds till the end says in the Book of
Revelations it does say that beasts
people think the beasts are viruses that
will wipe out at least two-thirds of all
humans
go to timcast.com become a member one of
our members only uncensored show coming
up for you at about 11 pm those are
always very fun and enlightening and uh
tomorrow's guest is going to be a lot of
fun I don't know should I should I
announce who tomorrow's guest is
yeah
I kind of feel like the guest is big
enough to where it's the it's the kind
that needs some you know some sort of
prefacing unless if the guest has
confirmed I would say yeah but if the
guest hasn't confirmed I mean it's all
confirmed it's just you never know I
mean publicly publicly if they've
confirmed publicly uh let me I tend to
err on the side of caution that's that's
a fair point let me check and then if
not I'll just give a hint I guess yeah
it'll be a fun show yeah I think it's
going to be really really big regardless
I think it's going to be real awesome
I'm so awesome that she's coming
definitely it's been an interesting week
here yeah I don't I don't think she's
she's announced okay I think people I
think if she did people would be
chatting us being like oh yeah for sure
I think for sure I'm excited this will
be a lot of fun
just rest assured I think you guys
should show up at 7 45 or so I think I
think people are going to be able to
guess but I'll just say it's one of the
most prominent what like female
conservatives uh yeah been in the
industry for a very long time yeah
politically active much longer than I've
been around so uh I think people could
probably guess conservative conservative
stop saying Tulsi gabbard it's not
Margaret Taylor green she found the show
before it was also not Steve Bannon
people are saying Lauren Southern
Lauren's been in the show several times
someone has never been on the show
before very prominent conservative
commentator but the thing where her
parents got banned from Airbnb was so
nuts
what and then they don't use it anymore
nobody nobody's guessing I think it's
kind of funny they're saying Marjorie
Taylor's gonna be a good show it's gonna
be one of those you're like oh I didn't
even think of that yeah it's gonna be
when you when you think about it you're
gonna be like how did I not get that God
come on
Roseanne Barr no but hopefully actually
no we are talking with Roseanne yeah uh
we just need to find it find it you know
Roseanne lives in New York right uh
Megan Kelly oh I will say Roseanne
someone talking to Roseanne yeah yeah
that's awesome yeah Roseanne we uh
Roseanne's awesome I've been a big fan
of hers since I was a kid and I watched
that show yeah we're trying to figure
out when we can get her to come on when
she's available when we have time Etc
that was like one of the only shows that
I ever watched with my act with like my
family and there was this one episode
where Becky did something wrong and
somehow like because Becky did something
wrong I got in trouble and I was like
what is good I'm not even Becky what are
you I'm more like Darlene first of all
second of all like I'm not on the TV
like I'm here in the house I'm watching
TV with you how could I be in trouble
we're gonna go to super chats but I just
want to point out many several people in
the chat have gotten it correct already
so uh you've guessed it correctly I'm
not telling you who or what but let's
read super chats all right waffle Sensei
says welcome to the show Sarah thank you
for having us fine and speaking truth
your voice can be one of the strongest
in the movement to save our kids we are
lucky to have you thank you well there
you go
all right Bullseye Ben oh is that a is
that a gold gem encrusted beanie from it
is this one is for you and you did
awesome in that cast castle video my
co-workers thought something was wrong I
was laughing so hard oh I was laughing
when I watched it so funny
the show is called Rhian with Ian that
was so fun when I was shooting it with
Wesley Wesley Roth was directing it
Aaron was there too and at one point
there were so many lines it was just one
of these scenes where he he wrote a lot
and he was like you can just kind of say
what you want you know this is the idea
but here's some things I want you to hit
and I was like gotten so frustrated and
I I like slammed the table and I was
like wow I hope that's on I hope that's
on camera because it was like a Bill
O'Reilly moment where I was like just
really I was getting into character like
feeling Steven's frustration of what
he's been going through the contract you
know like watch it cast Castle it's on
YouTube and on timcast.com some I don't
understand you know I guess this will
kind of give it away but everybody was
guessing names and like two people got
it right and we were like yeah we think
a couple you got it right and then all
of a sudden everyone just guessed the
right answer at the same time yeah all
right let's read more let's read more uh
yes and also I just want to shout out
you may notice that they're now little
Beanie emojis for those who are members
on the YouTube channel to chat and um
there's uh they're beanie Badges and
there's different colors depending on
what level you are so like the highest
level I think is an American flag yes an
American flag beanie and that's how long
it's been three years right yeah you got
to be there for a while I don't think
anyone's on there it's all about how
long you've consecutively been a member
correct yeah and then what we're gonna
do is we're gonna make another tier of
pure silliness which will give you a
golden
rooster badge and a bunch of different
chicken emojis and just because I don't
know yo we got one in the chat it got
one What A Chicken Little America beanie
on the chat or should that oh really oh
look at this yeah there you go whoa
there's an American beanie yes you've
got an American flag beanie that means
you've been a member for what 36 months
I think it's more than that 36 months
yeah 48 months we haven't gotten yet
yeah wow long time remember yeah shout
out to us Smith with the red pills
what's up dude yeah people posting red
pills yeah we got emojis tonight too
sang the names of people yeah all right
I say federally says on AI I was a young
pothead building half pipes idea uh
d-i-r through Windows 3.1 found Dr
Watson my friends would make it cuss I
told it to calculate pi and it went on
forever supposedly not IBM's Watson
Gates gave city names to OS code names
could Sydney be Australia the next OS
have you guys ever uh you ever heard of
Dr spetso No you want to look that up
yeah it was just like I don't even know
what it was I just remember that you
could you could type in say a word and
it would yeah dude this is like one of
the original speak yeah creative Labs
yeah I had Dr Smith yeah and you'd be
like you know say something and then it
would the robotic voice would say 1991
MS DOS uh and you could literally came
with the name is an acronym for Sound
Blaster artificial intelligence
text-to-speech organizer Sound Blaster
it was a sound blaster thing
Sound Blaster artificial well yeah that
s s is a member just s and with an
American flag beanie the ultimate top
tier beanie there's Eric ailman was in
there too oh yeah yeah and then we're
gonna make the uh the chicken tier
memberships which will be like
needlessly more expensive because if you
want it you can have it but it's like a
choice and then we'll put a whole bunch
of chicken emojis and your badge will be
a golden
I love the American flag beanie yeah
yeah that's cool JT fire says I did not
know that I needed Biden and Trump
playing OverWatch by the Nader forever
yeah I found it funny because I
literally play OverWatch before the show
and I'm wondering if I get indoors so so
I don't know if you guys ever play
OverWatch you guys are playing oh yeah
the first one I haven't touched the
second one yet oh I'm playing OverWatch
too and I'm I know that I'm really good
because after every match whether I win
or lose everyone endorses me and my
username is timcast so that must mean
I'm really good at the game like because
everyone's they click the button saying
they like you no I think people are
probably just like they know who I am
and they're like oh yeah shout out or
something but you know I I don't know I
only like playing No Limits I don't like
playing ranked or any of that do you
ever go in voice chat be like you know
who I am no why would I do that hey what
character are you using right now what's
your name oh man I don't know probably
symmetra I like but but Moira I'm like
un undefeatable like just I'll get like
15 player kill streaks I think more more
is just like an easy character to play
yeah Moira but uh symmetra is the most
fun because if you know how to place the
Sentry turrets and clever ways it's just
like you're playing these casual games
these people don't understand because
they're looking for
I don't know they're looking for
movement no no the Sentry turrets you
place and then they try and blow them up
because they're shooting at him but you
I put them on like lamp posts or you put
them in crevices you put them in weird
places where they're hard to see and
hard to shoot at and then but my
favorite is playing No Limits when
everyone plays symmetra and then we just
line the end the the enemy's door with
Sentry turrets and as they walk out they
instantly it sounds like NATO
all right enough OverWatch talk anyway
that video made me laugh a lot because
I've been playing OverWatch a lot
all right what do we got
because reason says deep fakes won't
exist in five years that's how fast this
is moving in five years you will make
your own porn whatever that happens to
be yes but what if if you can you can
make a video of Joe Biden declaring war
and it'll be indistinguishable
you could make a video of Joe Biden
declaring war while doing porn
yeah oh yeah
can I just say to everybody who plays
OverWatch I just want to I'll have the
opportunity with so many people who
listen to this show please fight on the
point can I just do you guys always
stand on the point I'm just I'm just I'm
so frustrated I know I'm just playing
casual I like playing No Limits but it's
like I'm on the I'm the only one on the
robot I'm the only one on the point and
they're chasing after the enemy getting
broken apart and then one Lucio jumps on
and and captures it and now we gotta
wait another five minutes and I'm like
my guys I understand if you're trying to
keep them off the point initially but
once they break your line you've gotta
stay on the robot yeah man if you have a
chance to take the core take the core
don't go get a mercenary Camp I'm
talking about Heroes of the Storm right
now do not dude there's a gift horse in
the mouth if you have an opportunity to
take it home take it home yo I had a
game where we were like 0.03 meters from
pushing the payload and then everyone's
just fighting off point and I'm like you
you realize the moment they go off we
win I just get on them some people play
for fun other people play to win so the
people that play for fun want combat
they want player versus player the
action they don't care about I know but
I like a little mix I'm not playing just
for like if I was gonna play just to win
it'd be ranked I like having fun and
playing different characters but I mean
you're still trying to win to a certain
Degree come on all right all right
anyway anyway
enough OverWatch talk H22 says Biden
needs to use AI chat to do his speeches
and pre-recorded videos I'd vote for him
uh if for that I mean that's a good
point why doesn't he just debake himself
yeah yeah there you go yeah somebody
should do that
weijin says deep fakes could be a win
for Legacy Media it could be the go-to
excuse to dismiss media online not true
didn't think about that uh no because
CNN posts fake news all the time they're
gonna they're gonna feel like trust us
we're real no you're not you're just
running make news on TV well and
certainly newspapers have posted fake
news all the time we just talked about
Jason player Ben Hixson says Tim Ian are
you looking forward to Atomic Hearts it
is a future era Soviet bioshock-like
game have you played prey 2016 has the
trolley problem oh that sounds fun I
haven't played that sounds interesting I
gotta say the first BioShock is a
masterpiece by the the subsequent
bioshocks are kind of meh BioShock
Infinite I think is okay but Bioshock
won the video game is Masterpiece you
know my type of games is like divinity
two uh I love isometric role-playing
games so I'm really looking forward to
Baldur's Gate 3 release and I'm gonna I
think we're gonna do a live stream of
that uh myself perhaps pixelated Apollo
he's into it and maybe gym if I don't
know if you're an RPGs or if that's
something you want to do I used to play
more RPGs when I was younger I was
playing Breath of Fire for a while
because I bought a Super Nintendo I love
oh yeah Breath of Fire bring the fire
was good I think I played Breath of Fire
I beat Mario RPG a couple months ago
it's remarkable playing our RPG as an
old man now because everything I do is
timed perfectly when I was a kid it was
like I'm playing Mario and I'm trying to
time it and I'm messing up now I'm old
and I'm playing this game for the first
time in 20 years and I'm just everything
is super easy and I'm I'm just like wow
this game's a lot easier punch out you
guys play Nintendo Punch Out Mike
Tyson's punch out it was so hard when I
was nine but now now it's not hard yeah
just read the cues no I haven't played
video games in a while but I did buy the
new Harry Potter game how is it I
haven't played it yeah because again I
haven't played video games in a while so
I still just have an Xbox One and so
apparently I can't play it till April is
the JK Rowling thing making it hard for
you to play the game no it's the fact
that I have an old system and can't play
so you're buying a new system in April
no it's actually pretty no no no so they
released it it's weird so like within
all the new consoles they released it
like last week with the older systems
like uh Xbox One and what like whatever
PS whatever PlayStation it was they were
they're not releasing it until like
April April 4th or something like that
yeah and so I think that because they
want you to get the new system to play
you know early releases and stuff
he says Tim your earlier stories of
Nikki Taylor and Chelsea are all
examples of why women deserve less why
women deserve less by Myron Gaines now
available for purchase for purchase
audiobook coming soon is that is fresh
and fit dude or what what was that
what's that about Nikki Haley yeah I
don't know what he's doing well I did
segments on Don Lemon saying she's
Pastor Prime Chelsea Chelsea Handler I
love this one Chelsea Handler responded
in a sense to Matt Walsh Tucker Carlson
Ben Shapiro me and Jesse Kelly because
we are all to a certain degree critical
of her video on her video about
masturbating and getting high and doing
drugs but but here's the thing
she included a picture of me in the
receding hairline club and I'm like okay
well I guess thank you Chelsea for
including me in this because she didn't
actually criticize anything I said about
her like Ben Shapiro called her
miserable Jesse Keller very hilariously
mocked her and Matt Walsh said something
similar but but my point that I made I
didn't say she was miserable or anything
like that I said people who don't have
kids are going to find themselves in
their deathbed in a sterile uh hospital
room the doctor is going to walk in and
say is there anyone we should call and
you'll say no and he'll say okay well
we're around call us if you need us and
then you're going to be sitting in this
room as you Lay Dying scared with no one
there to be to be there for you or to
comfort you I didn't say she was
miserable I think she's probably happy
as a pig and well we've already been
swearing in the show right she's
happiest of picking as she wakes up
does drugs and masturbates that sounds
like she's having a blast I mean maybe
she's a good auntie or something I don't
know I don't think aunties will have
people around me I heard that argument
that you were saying about having kids
to have people around you and you're old
I don't know if I'd like that as an
argument of why because if you just get
a bunch of women pregnant you're gone
nope and you never see your kids they
don't give they're not gonna come no one
cares about you they will count on your
deathbed if you're an they will
come if you're an amazing human being
with no kids you might have people all
around you near the end of your life
that just support you and are reminding
you that what you did on Earth was
valuable so I don't know well you'd have
to make friends with people who are
younger than you because by the time
you're old all your friends are dead
right like fans of your work and things
like that or like people you Mentor or
something or like you know if you're if
you have um nieces or nephews or Foster
families people that you Foster are like
you know this is in the Arts there were
always young people who are being
um you know friends with older artists
and stuff I don't know I think that's a
good point though if you're like the
cool aunt then maybe the cool Auntie is
a thing that's a thing that everybody
has their Auntie yeah the other thing I
wonder too is like maybe she can't have
kids and she doesn't want to come out
and say that she's Barren and so she
tries to find ways to justify a positive
feeling around it and if that is the
case it's really brutal to mocker and
call her miserable like maybe she's
trying to make the best of a really bad
situation and she's she really is deep
down inside sad that it never happened
for her or she can't so she's just like
well I can do drugs and masturbate and
everyone's just ragging on her and
mocking her I'm like you know it's kind
of brutal you know well did she even
write that bit it probably not it was
like she probably was like okay I'll do
that bit the bit was bad because it was
like does she not have a job you know
it's like it's not kids that make it so
you can't
wake up and do drugs and masturbate it's
like responsibility in general yeah so
she clearly has none and that sounds
really depressing just make funny jokes
basically I don't know she doesn't she's
that's not China
you know did you guys have Sarah
Silverman's hosting the Daily Show yeah
yeah I have no idea
Sarah Silverman is not funny her bit has
always been just to offend you but then
it got funny because once offending
people became taboo she didn't know what
to do yeah and now she's for National
divorce she is yeah oh yeah she made
that video like last year yeah yeah and
then we liked her we were like oh okay
well you know we can agree on that
she would live in America too I think is
what she said American too we could have
America one because it's important to us
oh look at this Angela McArdle is that a
silver beanie with blue gems encrusted
on it that's a long time membership
Sarah's work is valuable to keep
conservative side of the culture war
from over correcting thank you and keep
fighting the good fight see you at the
anti-war rally Sunday yes thank you
Angela
um she's the chair of the lp and we are
doing the anti-war rally The Rage
Against the war machine on Sunday 12 30
starting at the uh the Lincoln Memorial
and it's gonna move to the White House I
have a speaking spot at the White House
so
um yeah hope to see everybody there
all right Thomas sidebottom says Bing is
connected to a live internet with chat
GPT the training set is closed Bing is
doing the same thing but with real human
response training data uh interesting
yeah
crazy
the Bing stuff looks fun man
I signed up for the for the early wait
list I'm hoping I can get access to it
rbk says I was Chase Bank with a
question and the operator was about to
ask questions to identify me and the guy
said oh never mind you've been voice
authenticated scary stuff
yeah because that means somebody could
just deep fake your voice and then call
in hi I'm John he's like okay you're
good what do you want to do with your
money give it to Bill
done oh
all right what do we got here what do we
got here John White says last week you
did a piece on George Kelly the AZ
Rancher being held on one million
dollars bail his family set up a give
send to go campaign titled George Allen
Kelly legal defense fund help get him
home much more to his story so keep
covering we should definitely figure
that one out maybe even send someone
down there to figure out what happened
this is the guy that they accused of
shooting an illegal immigrant who was uh
multiple felonies or something like that
you like kept crossing the border and
people had reported multiple gunshots
earlier in the day so they arrest the 73
year old guy and they're holding him on
a million dollars bail which like makes
no sense because where's this guy going
to go I guess because he lives on the
border they're like I don't know 10 feet
over the Border
it's like well the federalis will bring
them back what are you talking about his
house is right there
all right all right
lightning fire says do you think AI will
be used by terrorists where anything can
be possible everything be off limits
would gun control even work with AI when
anyone can build with 3D printing
machine
imagine how crazy it's going to be when
in the future when you just go to the
AIA the AI and 3D printing advances well
beyond just Plastics and Pla or whatever
abs and it can Mill metal and mold metal
and you're like I'd like an AR-15
mil-spec please 556 and it's like okay
and then it just starts making all the
parts and puts it all together for you
perfectly form fit to your hand hey for
that matter in Star Trek how come they
never did that you know because Star
Trek was uh Star Trek was trying to look
at us as our best selves but like they
could make a phaser if they needed one
could they they couldn't replicate
phasers why not I think it was the
replicator didn't do it I'm pretty sure
the replicator did the replicator do it
I thought the replicator the kid makes
food I think food is more complicated
that's already pretty incredulous like
that's ridiculous yeah that was
definitely the fantasy part of that food
I guess the idea of Star Trek was at the
the naycells would absorb free hydrogen
and then use that matter in the
replicators and convert it into denser
material Fusion in the matter replicator
yeah and bonding to chemical bonding and
you'd be like I'd like a cheeseburger
and it would make one but what what do
you do with the cup like you know a car
would be like tea Earl Gray hot and then
it makes the glass then he takes the
glass out you didn't see he just throws
it in the trash can throw it out the
window or something what happens
the crazy thing is technically based on
the lore of Star Trek you could
replicate people
really well they that's what the
Transporters do like the episode where
Riker got split into two people
confirmed from Wikipedia yes they can
recycle the replicators do recycle
things can they make phasers
I don't know it's probably a big article
they can make bat lifts for sure what
about a gun oh they did I think well
they can make a spoon or a knife but
imagine like a big a funny parody where
it's like replicate me at Glock 17. I
want a Tommy Gun fully loaded right well
the the holiday yeah yeah of course and
then they get shot
that's so dumb and then when you take
the safeties off yeah and then you have
a whole episode of being scared of the
house we're trapped in the Holodeck and
they're going to shoot us
that show was fun oh I love it all right
where are we at it's my like Comfort
show special shout out to Levar Burton
and Reading Rainbow Buddy b says I've
been I've been tentative about
membership due to funds but would hunt
would 100 throw money at Ian for morning
meditation factory work these days calls
for Zen you want to wake up at 8am no
but if you do have to wake up at 8am
meditating is one of the best things you
can do if you want to clear your mind
and be refreshed for the day stretching
first thing I do when I wake up is I
stretch what we'll do is we'll record at
midnight yeah because it's technically
the morning
and then it'll be uploaded at 8 AM for
everybody but it'd be nicer Ian's
midnight meditation yeah live stream
because I think the power of multiple
humans meditating together regardless of
where we are the entanglement instead of
just watching waffles that previously
happened waffle says Tim you're playing
OverWatch with 12 year old bro it's not
going to get better I'm sorry I know I
know that's the case
so did they dance over you when you die
you can really tell when you're playing
against a team well that's the funny
thing it's like I've played where I mean
dude it's such a fast-paced game
if you start teabagging you you're done
like I'm gonna walk up and then you
start doing a stupid thing and then
you're instantly wiped out
is it uh does the ridicule is how you
pronounce that word reticule that's what
I call it does it bounce or does it
always straight in the middle no matter
how fast you're moving no matter if you
jump It's always directly in the middle
of the screen or does it like bounce and
whatever you're running that's not why I
never got into OverWatch because I felt
like I was playing Borderlands 2 and I
like the Gunplay of Borderlands 2. I
felt a lot more realistic and
challenging like if you're running you
don't have like perfect aim when you're
running it's not kind of robotic
OverWatch Brett ain't dead and the
member chat says Tim what do you play
OverWatch on either way add me same name
on here real Crush 86 babies
um I play on PS5 and my username is
timcast and I imagine the next time I
turn my PlayStation on it's gonna go
bling bling bling bling request from
request friend request and uh
it's it's fun playing with a real team
and you know you're playing with other
30 year old men because everyone T like
groups up before running in when you can
tell you're playing with little kids
because everyone dies sporadically and
then run out one at a time also their
whole team is there just five shot like
you know five versus one five versus one
and I'm just like please just wait 20
seconds for the group to come together
rushing in wait for five wait for five
click the Leroy Jenkins right that's
exactly I'll play at night and like you
can tell people are getting drunker and
higher the later the night goes on
because like by 3 A.M uh no one's even
talking on chat
Aunt 345 says Bungie is woke as hell but
I love Destiny Hunter class for Life
yeah I stopped playing Destiny a while
ago I played Destiny since the beginning
of it and then I can't remember the last
one I played
um destiny 2 is like one of the last
ones I played well there's a bunch of
expansions so the last one I played I
think was when the darkness was released
and you were able to wield the darkness
or whatever
I'm not familiar with Destiny yeah
Destiny's fun game hey Ian so when do
you wake up
uh it depends on the day I woke up at
one today okay I woke up at 9 00 a.m
yesterday for a 10 a.m meeting I try to
take late meetings I usually start my
day around two I work two to eleven
basically so I get up around one go to
bed about three a.m usually that's fair
Nelson nelville says cast has anyone
ever recognized you while gaming Ian
Does anybody recognize you while gaming
or anything uh not not uh unless they
know I'm gaming ahead of time and I
always feel it feels weird like I like
the anonymity that was a big problem of
why I kind of dipped out on social media
for a decade is because like I was going
to chat rooms and we were all having a
genuine conversation then I started to
get well known and when I'd go into the
chat room the conversation would stop
and people would be like Ian's here Ian
Ian I'm like no I just want to have a
conversation
so no the short answer is no for me um
my PlayStation username has always been
Tim cast well before I had any
substantial amount of followers
so I just log into the same thing every
time
but my joke earlier was I get endorsed
every time I play and I don't think it's
because I'm good at the game I think
people are just like oh hey Tim cast you
know and they click endorse so it's like
you've been endorsed and I'm just like
yeah I'm pretty sure I was nuts
being famous it's like do those people
really like me do they really like me or
they just I hate that well I'm playing
casual I'm not playing ranked if I was
playing ranked they might be like hey
it's cool you're here dude but you're
costing us the game you know what I mean
not true so playing the Casual stuff
like No Limits where you just get like
six symmetras to all run at the same
time and pepper everything with turrets
is just the most hilarious thing ever
and then the one thing I can't stand is
when everyone thinks it's funny to play
mercy and I'm like what do you guys
think like six healers on one person is
gonna stop you from losing I don't know
whatever it's fun though
it's all good fun
all right Mr jusno says isn't drinking
distilled water bad for you I remember
hearing that it lacks the minerals
thereby diluting the mineral levels in
your cells that is correct at least
that's what I understand right yeah
you're supposed to reintroduce minerals
and that's why our filtration system has
added minerals right yeah oh yeah in
addition if to uh filter Vinyl chloride
out of your water I heard that you could
do activated charcoal and reverse
osmosis combine those two things
apparently here we go
Jason Dixon's got a gold beanie with red
Jewels encrusted to it and he says two
years seven months 23 days get on my
level yes get on his level
yeah yeah yeah I don't know maybe maybe
uh there's other stuff we can add to
make YouTube memberships mean something
more I mean
the the the issue I suppose is
there is a chat now and and we're
getting massive feedback from people
being like we can actually have
conversations this is cool people were
using chicken City this is the thing
people don't understand they would they
would turn the show on and then open
chicken City and use the chicken City
live stream chat as the chat for this
show these are things that we saw where
we're like okay this chat clearly isn't
working what can we do so you can always
go hang out in chicken City live stream
chat for free and talk about whatever
you want
or we figured the membership thing is a
way to make a clean chat with no limits
so you don't gotta wait five six seconds
or whatever and you can just chat I like
it golden Gaming's saying free to chat
Almighty Antichrist nobody cares Dash Z
Dash love it like you guys are I can see
you now and oh tracer's in the chat red
beanies equals Maga beanies
maybe we should put MaGa on the red
beanie
we could do that yeah a little Maga
there's also the 20-sided the 20 on the
20-sided die and the one on the 20-sided
die yeah but it's hard to see the number
so that was about rolling 20s so we'll
have to figure that one out we already
got that coming on the update so okay
cool cool and then we're gonna we're
gonna create the uh the golden
girl okay so uh smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends become a
member at timcast.com we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you in
about one hour and it's gonna get pretty
serious because we got some uh very
serious stuff to talk about that might
be too spicy for this family friendly
version of the show you can follow the
show at timcastirl you can follow
timcast news on Facebook where we're
going to be publishing our news articles
and you can help by sharing them if you
think they're important and that's uh
Tim cast news on Facebook and you can
follow me personally at timcast and uh
my other YouTube channel is youtube.com
timcast news for those that aren't
familiar and I've been doing that longer
than this one but I'm now doing six
segments per day on that channel so it's
like two hours of content it's another
podcast I have called the Tim pool Daily
Show which has about half as many
viewers as this show but I don't think
there's a strong overlap so if you want
to check it out you can check it out uh
yeah Sarah you wanna shout anything out
yeah so if you want to go find me just
go to my my website which is Sarah
higdon.com it has links to all my social
media platforms I'm on just about
everything but just like my YouTube is
youtube.com Sarah Higdon and then
Twitter and Instagram is both just Sarah
Higdon with an underscore after it and
so that's it and yeah come on Sunday and
I'll see you guys out there if you guys
come out to the anti-war Alex Sunday
someone made a uh Miguel is saying I
would do Tim cast after show at four if
it were live
that's a really good point and um we're
gonna look into that because I think it
is possible to do a private members only
live stream on Rumble which you need to
figure out how to do it yeah yeah we can
do it definitely do that I'm pretty sure
we could we've been asked before to do
it I believe because we can do the
members only as a live stream on
timcast.com yeah it save us some time
after is there a live chat because
that'll get wild if people are talking
about yeah probably if they're Rumble
yeah I imagine that would be cool let's
figure it out because then we could take
questions and stuff from the members as
well that would be that would be lit
that was your question yeah anyway yeah
Olivia anything else sure I'm at Libya
month on Twitter and you can check out
what we're doing at
thepostmillennial.com every day I'm Ian
Crossland follow me at Ian crossland.net
subscribe to me on YouTube at Ian
Crossland and you can also check out
this cast Castle skit on cast Castle
YouTube channel and timcast.com I just
want to give a special shout out to
Amish man Joseph RG rg2 Tracer Ted
Thornton I know I already mentioned you
Tracer and Brett ain't dead Tracer is an
OverWatch character you guys in chat you
make this happen well we make this
happen and you're here with us making it
happen make it happen together happy to
be here with you thanks for being here
bye and I am at search.com follow me on
Twitter it's at
s-e-r-g-e-d-o-t-c-o-m everyone doesn't
get it right I keep telling me about
that it's spell it out with an e and I
will go argue with you I do respond to
everything at least I try my best too
cheers I want to stress the uh cast
castle video so go to youtube.com cast
castle for one reason Ian is arguing
with Roberto Jr on the phone and he's he
secretly recorded Roberto Junior's
conversation and I just you know I love
chicken so I find it very funny I I
thought it was hysterical
that's so funny what was that what does
that recording device you have it's
awesome it's called Wesley I called it a
Teddy Ruxpin I know it's not that it's
not a talk boy but that's what uh if you
saw Stephen Fisher Price
all right check that out and uh Teddy
Ruxpin era we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out